Yep. All right.
Thanks, Daniel, for having me.
Everyone at the active entrance lab staff.
Canceling twice.
Life's been kind of crazy
with finishing this book
that this talk will be about
and having a kid at six months old.
And I got sick,
like, a week ago, like, right.
Leading up to.
I didn't want to cancel a third time.
Look crazy.
So this is a very rushed presentation.
It'll be better
if it's more of, like, a conversation
and since I haven't even gone
through the slides myself once,
and it's
going to get into a lot of things,
like immediately
like open up bags and worms.
Like, there's just philosophical issues,
things that people won't agree about,
like immediately.
But yes.
So this is just going to be like
a small introduction to the thesis.
In the book.
And yeah.
Explain more, I guess.
After I begin so yeah, it's
called this the
integrated evolutionary synthesis
compared to like the modern synthesis
or even the extended evolutionary
synthesis is integrated because it
kind of reconceptualize is evolution,
biology and evolution in terms. Of.
In terms of thermodynamics
and information theory
or energy flows, energy
and information flows
takes from cybernetics
so yeah, it's a non reductive theory
of everything
that includes emergent phenomena
like life, mine and civilization.
I. Say that
because most theories of everything
we're used to are fundamental physics
theories that don't have anything to say
about life and consciousness.
They ignore in
and I don't think those should be called
theories of everything,
because theories of everything should be
an explanation for everything.
And if you believe the things
that we care about most out.
Then.
It's not much of a theory of everything.
So this is the book.
I've spent the last two to three years
writing obsessively.
And it's available for preorder now.
So if you want to check that out,
you can find it within Google search.
Here is the table of Contents.
So the book is broken into three
sections.
Part one talks.
About the origins. Of life.
And part two about evolution,
while part three.
Focuses on.
Consciousness and free will
and the fate of life in the universe.
So these are really big questions
that we're going to focus on.
Part two.
And give a pretty.
Like a. Superficial.
Overview of part two.
But you can.
Feel free to ask me any questions about
any of the other topics that are related
and I'll try to see what I can answer
without going into.
All of the.
Information
that I would need to explain this things.
So Thomas Huxley,
known as Darwin's Bulldog,
because he was such a strong advocate
for Darwin's theory,
said that the question of questions
for mankind the problem
which underlies all others is more
deeply interesting than any other,
is the ascertainment and of the place
which man occupies in nature
and of his relations
to the universe of things.
So where do we fit
into the grand cosmic scheme?
Most scientists
in the 20th century,
and I would even say.
Now believe.
That we are an accident.
So Jack Monroe.
French
biochemist who won the Nobel Prize
for Physiology and Medicine.
And wrote a.
Book called Chance Incest,
which was really influential. And.
He was just as reductionist
as you can get.
Man at Last knows that he is alone
in the unfeeling immensity
of the universe, out of which he emerged
only by chance neither.
So some of the words
are covered by by Daniel.
So either it's his destiny spelled out
nor his duty.
Have. Been written down.
I think something wrong with that quote.
But so if there are times
I'm trying to read something
where the is over, I might have to skip.
You can you can move that
because it looks good on my site.
It it looks fine. Thank you. Yeah.
Neither his destiny
nor his duty have been written down,
so that was kind of
based on this old idea that
the emergence of life
was a product of chance assembly
so like this just
statistical fluctuation
that brought together all the molecules
needed to create the first cell.
We now know that that's probably not
what happened.
It's this gradual process
of self-organization.
Jeremy England has
been in the media a lot about his theory
of dissipated adaptation.
So let's
so we will see.
This is kind of
like a different point of view.
Not everybody was convinced.
By a monster.
Carl Sagan said the origin of life
must be a highly probable warfare
as soon as conditions permit.
Up it parts.
So this is an important question.
Whether
life was improbable or inevitable.
So if life is highly improbable,
we're likely to be alone in the universe.
But if the emergence of life
is inevitable,
given a certain set of common.
Physical.
Conditions,
then it's likely that we have life
at least on planets
that are sufficiently earthlike
specifically have geochemistry
like the Earth.
Have a star.
Some like the.
Earth's because that's. What.
Provides the energy that pushes
it far from equilibrium.
So we're going to get in. To.
All that stuff pretty soon.
Christian, to do this quote is kind of a.
Response to Stephen J.
Gold, who just really emphasized.
To. Both Meno and Stephen J.
Called the.
The importance of chance.
In. Nature,
and that everything is basically,
you know, a contingency
that came from a chance process.
Where.
They do
says that you can have this inevitability
at some philosophers
would see us as teleology.
But it doesn't mean that.
This inevitable progress is being driven
by a supernatural force.
He explains that the natural constraints
within which chance operates
are such that evolution
in the direction of increasing complexity
was virtually bound to take place if
given the opportunity, chance does not.
Exclude. Inevitability.
So he was also a Nobel Prize
winning biologist
the same category as minor,
but had the complete opposite opinion.
And we can talk about that too.
Basically,
when systems are open systems
and they're pushed far from equilibrium.
By. A flow of energy,
you basically get something like.
A. Statistical bias away from what
we would expect with isolated systems.
Closed systems that. Are.
Open to energy
will relax the thermodynamic equilibrium.
And when a system is being pushed
far from equilibrium,
it will naturally
organize because organization
happens.
Under the flow of.
Energy.
And we're going to see exactly
why it's a Darwinian process.
But basically
you get inevitability
if you have the right ingredients.
So we'll talk about.
To kind of frame this.
We already
kind of mentioned those two worldviews.
So the first world.
View would be the reductionist worldview.
And I should be clear that.
Reductionism. Is
also it's a method in an ideology,
and we shouldn't
confuse those two things.
And Daniel, I guess
just so I'm know where I'm at, maybe
when you, when I've gone 30 minutes,
you can let me know.
OK, or who.
OK, great.
So reductionism the method
basically says
that reality can be understood
by breaking down all physical phenomena
into their simplest parts
so that we may observe the basic
behavior of the fundamental
constituents of nature. So
you know,
plug in this. Charge.
I might get to do that.
But basically the.
Method is how science works.
If we want to.
Understand emergence, we also have
to understand how the components
that systems are made of work
in isolation.
So it's an essential.
Part of the.
Story, but it's not the whole part.
We'll see.
So the method inspired an ideology,
and ideology is is is just that.
It's it's an ideology and it's rigid.
And basically the method
doesn't really
imply that that ideology is true.
So when I'm attacking reductionism,
I'm not attacking the method.
I'm attacking the worldview.
And so that worldview,
we can say that basically.
So. Hard determinism
is part of the reductionist worldview.
So thought experiment
that some people are familiar with.
I'm sure the place is Daemon.
Basically.
The class was.
A. French mathematician that.
I took.
Newton's kind of model of reality.
And. Applied it to everything.
Newton himself was kind of a mystic
when it comes to life.
He didn't really think that physics
applied. To.
Two organisms, or at least to humans. But
Laplace really, you know,
came up with the idea that, like,
basically the evolution of the universe
is just this.
Like clockwork.
Universe, where it's like
a machine with cogs
that are just turning.
So there are no there's no room
for agency and free will in that picture.
When Boltzmann came along
in the 19th century and
came up with statistical mechanics,
the clockwork universe kind of became
the billiard ball universe.
But it's just the idea that everything in
the universe is made of atoms.
And at these atoms are
interacting and that's the whole picture.
So the ideology says
we're nothing more than our atoms,
so we don't make decisions.
Consciousness is just an empty phenomenon
and it feels to us like we are.
But actually this trajectory
was determined basically
at basically
from the moment of the Big Bang.
And there's kind of
no freedom in anything and no future
other than
what was determined from the beginning.
So the second law of thermodynamics.
Also sort of shaped
the reductionist worldview.
Says the universe is becoming
increasingly disordered.
There's actually kind of two different
interpretations of the second law.
The first one.
Kind of emerged from the work of.
Karnow and Classiest, the kind. Of.
Original thermodynamics work
where entropy was about.
A measure of.
Energy that can't be used for work.
So a kind of measure
of what use less energy,
where later with Boltzmann, he tried. To.
Put the second law on like
statistical basis
based on like atomic theory.
So basically
people applied Boltzmann
statistical interpretation
of the second law to the universe
and came up with this notion
that the universe
is becoming increasingly disordered,
which isn't great for life,
because it means that life is transient
and likely cosmically insignificant.
And this world view
is associated with materialism,
which doesn't recognize
consciousness as real, certainly doesn't
recognize it as having causal power.
And. Historically, it often ignored
apparently immaterial phenomena
like energy
and information, mental processes.
I am.
Just going. To.
Grab my charger. So
sounds good.
This doesn't die
but I will be right back.
Take your time
so those who are watching
live, please feel free to leave a comment
or a question.
I'm writing some things down.
We'll look forward
to the return of electrical power
to Bobby
All right.
My first live.
I will be more prepared when I return.
Part two.
That's something else I told Daniel
is that this is kind of like part one
that I could come back and.
Talk about
the. Ideas that come after.
So it will have 15.2 it'll be awesome.
It's an infinite sequence.
It's the sequence is always joyous.
Great.
OK. So
reductionist worldview
says that all lifeforms,
including humans, are nothing more
than collections of atoms
literally following fixed and arbitrary
mechanical trajectories.
Term and solely by. Math and not by mind.
So this worldview, if if.
You convince someone that they don't have
free will because you tell them about.
The reductionist worldview.
There's actually a study
where they did this and they read
participants a passage from Francis Crick
explaining
that it appears
that we don't have any free will.
The participants actually on.
Subsequent tests.
Were more like more likely.
To cheat on the. Test.
Because they felt like they didn't have
any personal responsibility.
They weren't making the decisions,
therefore they could cheat.
That's kind of funny because they are
actually you can see that.
By what.
They're being told,
they are changing their behavior.
So it is having some kind of effect
if we do in fact have agency
or free will and.
We're.
Kind of talking about agency,
we don't really get into free will,
but those are related topics.
But if that's not true.
Then that's really bad that the majority
of scientists are telling people
we don't have free will
because the people that believe this,
it's having negative
effects on, for example, mental health.
Other studies have shown.
That.
Belief
and no free will can lead to depression.
And belief in free
will can have all these positive effects.
Of course.
As soon as I start
talking about free will,
I'm sure a lot of people have objections
you might think that there's no way
that we can have room for free
will in a physical worldview.
But that's exactly what we're going
to begin to talk about today.
That causal power of information
and that basically organisms are agents
that are cybernetic control units.
So as controllers.
We do have agency.
So in the belief
that we're accidents of nature
rather than natural manifestations
of physical laws.
I'm sure also in our sense.
Of well-being.
Just so you know, I'm not making this up.
I can I'll give you some.
Quotes from.
Really famous physicists.
Who are. Kind of militant reductionist.
So Brian Greene
says, I think it's very important
to face up to the truth of reality,
which is in fact,
that life and consciousness is
a fleeting phenomenon
on the entire cosmological timeline.
Brian Greene just came out with a book,
and he's like going on interviews
just saying this.
And it's really interesting
because some other famous physicists
don't agree at all, and he's stating it
like it's complete facts.
So, for example,
David Deutsch would not agree with this,
and we'll get into that Sabine Pass.
And Felder is another person
I know some of the
some of my friends in the community,
who are these people
working on emergence and causation stuff?
I get bothered by her statements
because she is also.
Very ultra. Reductionistic.
So I wish people would stop insisting
they have free will.
It's terribly annoying.
Insisting that free will exists
is bad science,
like insisting that horoscopes
tell you something about the future.
It's not compatible
with our knowledge about nature. So
I'm saying that's wrong.
We want to be into free will that much.
But if you have questions at the end,
we will talk about
how information, adaptive information
gets built up by evolution
in adaptive systems, complex
adaptive systems
and you will see how these systems
actually do control their own future.
So Sam Harris is another anti-free
wheel person
says you're not controlling this storm
and you are not lost in it.
You are the storm.
So it's kind of funny
because he's using a metaphor here.
But what this story kind of reveals
is that
yes, we are a storm.
That's right.
We are a dissipated structure.
Like a storm.
Emerges to dissipate an energy gradient.
And we're not really going
to talk about that.
That's what the first part of the book is
about, the origins part. But
I'm just
pointing it out because it's interesting
because we are like a storm
in that aspect.
But we also. Differ from a storm.
Because a.
Storm does not have agency,
a storm does not have the ability
to seek out new energy gradients.
It's just kind. Of.
Being pushed around by these gradients
in nature.
Where.
Organisms are actually.
Controllers.
And so you are storm.
But you do.
Have control over. This storm.
So these people are kind of
have the opposite view.
So Julio Tanoni,
creator of Integrated Information
Theory, says there is true free will.
Great lecture that just popped up,
I think, months ago where he gives
a two hour talk
on basically integrated information
and how it shows that systems
do have causal power and in a. Way.
Have free will.
So depending on
your definition of free will.
We do have free will.
According to his model.
David Deutsch said in an interview
with John Horgan just a year ago or so.
I'm sure we have free will, Christof Koch
says, explains how, you know,
there are a lot of experiments
still about experiments
which we will talk about next time that
basically, yeah,
some people interpret
it as not having free will, but actually
we will see later.
When you deliberate.
That's actually an act of free
will, these choices
where we're actually where
you bring your entire conscious being
to that question and try to analyze it.
Under all the.
Various conditions
and actually there was a study cook
did that kind of show that the debate,
the study
was kind of interpreted wrong. And
for anyone
who understands that stuff, the readiness
potential that was supposed to be proof
that there was no free will disappeared
when the decisions involved deliberation.
So yeah, that's kind of meandering
but I'm sure a lot of people
are interested in this bigger.
Picture of.
Why this emergence paradigm
is so radically different
from the reductionist paradigm.
It kind of.
Puts.
Information front and center and systems
that process information.
Complex.
Adaptive systems,
our computational systems
and these systems.
In. The with these systems information
actually does
have causal power we're going to explain
what we mean by that.
So paradigm of emergence,
the collective says the collective.
Behavior of interacting parts,
not simply how they function in isolation
is key to understanding the emergence
and evolution of all the fascinating
organisms and ecosystems
that make up the biosphere.
So it's really not about
just like particles.
It's about the patterns that emerge
when these systems find these certain
configurations
through basically Darwinian mechanisms.
And we'll see that
self-organization, too, has a Darwinian.
Dynamic.
Each emergence
in the cosmic self-organization process
is brought about by higher order
phase transition that moves life ever
further away from a state
of thermodynamic equilibrium.
In total disorder.
I'm assuming the audience knows
what thermodynamics equilibrium is.
It's basically
if you have, for example, Boltzmann
to a model. Of.
An ideal gas
and explained that, for example,
if the gas molecules are bunched
up in the corner, naturally it's going
the gas is going to spread out
until there's no pattern.
And basically
it's like a completely mixed up state.
So. Equilibrium
is associated with death and disorder.
Because systems.
Naturally tend toward.
This more.
Next. Step.
On patterned completely chaotic state.
Of course.
Later we're going to talk about.
Why. Open systems
that that rule doesn't apply.
Basically, systems
that are open to the flow of energy
can resist this tendency
towards a disorder.
And that's really.
What the whole story is kind of
based on.
So through that series of such phase
transitions, these are also called
these higher order phase transitions
are major evolutionary transitions.
John Maynard Smith talked about them
and Metis system transitions
by the Cybernet is this Valentine Turgeon
basically the same concept.
There's some subtle differences.
So the idea is that cosmic
self-organization is a series of these
transitions where functional things
come together to make larger
functional ones which come together
to even make even larger ones and so on.
And through this process,
adaptive complexity or life.
So that's a more general way
to talk about life
becomes better
equipped to dominate the cosmos.
Life requires an organization
that is increasingly hierarchical
and integrated and therefore more
resilient and computationally powerful.
So here are just a couple of.
Figures you see this hierarchy
in this structural hierarchy
of matter in life.
This was adapted from.
A big. Physics journal. I can't remember.
Which one it was, but.
Basically physicists are
recognizing this hierarchy,
even when it extends to life.
So Jeffrey Westbrook scale comes to mind.
And so we see the hierarchy of science
kind of naturally mirror
this hierarchy of matter and life.
And the reductionist picture would say
that these things at the top here
are kind of insignificant
parts of the story, transient.
But we will see that this you know.
The more we go up.
The more influence on cosmic evolution.
The phenomena have.
Cells.
Thomas Huxley's question
about man's place in the cosmos.
Is basically the emergence of paradigm
the paradigm of.
Emergence. I'm going to discuss.
And actually this is kind of
maybe like in a specific
or a new paradigm of emergence
because it includes all this stuff
about thermodynamics and information
theory says that emergence,
the emergence and evolution
of life, modern societies and technology
are all part of one thermodynamic
process, one evolutionary process,
one computational process
unified by the concept of knowledge.
So this theory is a
theory of knowledge creation.
And so knowledge
is going to be the unifying theme.
And we'll briefly
talk about epistemology.
I wanted to talk about it more,
but it just would have been too long.
Cosmic evolution
in this paradigm is a universal process
of becoming as opposed to being.
So the universe isn't this static thing.
It's actually evolving
very much like an organism
or a complex adaptive system.
So it's not a can psychic theory
in this theory,
consciousness emerges
that's very important.
But you might. Call
it emergent pants like.
Ism because.
As this evolutionary process precedes
inanimate matter,
as life spreads gets converted into.
Animate matter.
So in this picture, humans are neither
a cosmic accident
nor the end goal of evolution.
So we are instead a step
on the evolutionary ladder of becoming
and we are also potentially an essential
driver of increasing cosmic complexity.
So this big idea that the universe
is undergoing this
majestic self-organizing process
and at this moment of time,
at least in this corner of the universe,
we are the stars of the show.
This picture is from Chasen's.
Book.
The Rise of Complex The Cosmic Evolution,
The Rise of Complexity.
He's a Harvard astrophysicist,
but I just use Freeman Dyson quote here
because it seemed irrelevant.
It's conceivable
that life may have a larger role
to play than we have yet imagined.
Life may succeed against all odds and
molding the universe to its own purpose.
So I guess Brian Greene
doesn't buy that at all.
But if that's true, then
as far as cosmology,
cosmologists have to think about. The.
Role of life.
There's a lot of people
that said similar things like celluloid
and famously Ray Kurzweil.
So just a couple of quotes here.
So, you know, when people hear these
terms progress, there's just this stigma.
Immediately they thought like,
oh, someone's trying to sneak in religion
or some intelligent design theory.
So you see these trusted names of physics
here.
David Deutsch, his narrowly conceived
evolutionary theory, considers
as mere vehicles for the replication
of our genes or means,
and it refuses to address
the question of why
evolution has tended to create ever
greater adaptive complexity.
Or the role that.
Such complexity
plays in the wider scheme of things.
So there is clearly implying
that adaptive complexity
does have this larger role to play
we now see how it is
possible for the universe to increase
both organization and entropy.
At the same time, the optimistic
and pessimistic areas of time
can coexist
the universe can display creative actual
you need directional progress
even in the face of the second law.
Physicist Paul. Davies says. That.
So that's really
kind of a key point.
In. This is that
the second law actually
is in a sense
driving this increase in progress.
So not.
Only can we have know directional
progress in the face of the second law,
it seems that this progress requires
the second law
because we'll see that
the second law is. The.
Basically the natural selection pressure
for self-organizing systems.
So in a sense, the second law is both Shiva the destroyer and Brahma the creator.
So a goal
of this unifying theory of reality.
I I've been.
Calling to great constituents.
It was actually a name
suggested by Marco Lin, who is is a PhD,
Estonian
and influenced some of this talk.
So basically the.
Unifying theory of reality illuminates
the connection between complexity
cognition, consciousness and cosmic
evolution or matter mind and cosmos.
And it's really based on complexity.
Science is a lot broader than complexity
science but I guess that name kind.
Of in a way. Includes everything.
So it's the unification of major sciences
of our time, including but not limited
to physics,
biology, neuroscience, computer science,
evolutionary theory and statistics,
and basically describes
complex adaptive systems of all scales
in terms of energy and information flows.
So it uses statistical
thermodynamics,
information theory and cybernetics.
So we will talk about those.
A bit.
Coming up.
So if you want to see kind of I.
Can a map of what sort of informs.
This non reductive theory of everything.
So. Here you go.
So I know the slide of information,
so I'll kind of try
to simplify this for everyone.
There are some unifying paradigms
that have emerged.
So basically this theory is nothing new.
It's basically evolutionary epistemology.
After that came universal
Darwinism and later
right now we're seeing
this kind of revolution with like
Bayesian inference in these ideas
being applied to everything.
So being informed.
By these
paradigms. And.
Combining those paradigms, updating them,
I should say, with
information from non equilibrium
thermodynamics that we're talking about,
the thermodynamics of open systems
information theory.
So Shannon's theory,
some of you will know that information
theory
is related very closely
to non equilibrium thermodynamics and.
Basically.
Boltzmann.
Statistical entropy is mathematically
the same as Shannon entropy
to information entropy,
which is a measure of uncertainty.
If I.
Had more time,
I would go through thermodynamics
and the different types of entropy.
But we. Don't have time for that.
But if anyone has any questions
I can clarify cybernetics. Was.
Basically information theory
applied to biology adaptive systems.
It was the first science
of adaptive systems, really.
And it's funny, while writing this
I found out because, you know, I.
Hadn't.
I had heard the name cybernetics,
but it wasn't clear.
How important it was
and I talked by Jim Crutchfield.
Santa Fe Institute
basically revealed that
because cybernetics got associated
with like the Russian.
Like during.
The Cold War, kind of like the Russian
agenda cybernetics,
which used to design like heat seeking
missiles.
Norbert
Weiner's theory was almost immediately
applied for military uses,
and because of that,
it stopped
being taught in American colleges.
So. Yeah, it's really important.
And it was actually
emerging at the same time
as information to people
were already thinking about systems
in terms of information flows.
But it's more than information theory
because it's the science of feedback.
So. Dynamical systems theory
or complex systems, it's
kind of like an offshoot of that.
All of these inform what I call universal
Bayesian ism, not the only person to.
Call it that.
I had searched that term
and found Adam Saffron's
paper on integrated world
modeling theory that use that same term.
But John Campbell has been a researcher.
Who has done.
A lot to show this equivalence between
evolutionary processes and processes
of Bayesian inference for
and talk about that in a little. Bit.
So yeah,
if anybody has any questions about that.
But really all of these things,
origin of life research, integrate
evolutionary theory
if you haven't checked out the work
of these people, like everybody here
is worth reading their work.
But so from that we get a unified
theory of reality
that is based on what I call
evolutionary physiology, universal
Darwinism,
universal Bayesian ISM framework.
That's a long. Name. I'm aware. Of that.
But it's just to show
that these three theories are basically
the same theory.
So. Universal
Darwinism says that the universe
is evolving at every scales
for both competitive evolution
and through self-organization,
which is cooperative evolution
among agents
that have formed a collective unit.
So it started with Richard Dawkins
and his concepts of the meme,
the selfish gene that means
where these cultural units
that were equivalent to genes.
And so we started to see how information.
Was this paradigm.
That can be extended beyond biology.
And then we had Dan Dennett and Darwin's
dangerous idea really extend this
to like everything to
self-organizing systems, to like cultural
and technological systems.
I evolutionary biology came before that.
It was based on Karl Popper's philosophy,
but it was actually invented
by cognitive psychologist
Donald Campbell.
And basically that said
that the evolutionary process
is a problem
solving procedure that creates knowledge.
So the information stored in genomes
and in
brains and cultural memory
basically that all that knowledge
accumulates from an evolutionary process.
And it's really helpful
to think of it as knowledge,
especially when we start to talk
about this.
In the.
Context of thermodynamics.
And information. Because.
Basically this knowledge is what allows
life adaptive systems
to stay far from equilibrium.
They can resist this tendency towards
decay.
Life can continue to persist
if it can acquire the knowledge
that it needs
to essentially to find free energy
that will allow it to sustain itself.
So we'll talk.
About that in a second. More
so Universe Bayesian ISM is a Bayesian
update of the first two paradigms.
Knowledge is encoded.
So the knowledge
that evolutionary cosmology described
it's actually encoded
in biological systems.
In the form. Of a world. Model.
So this model is an internal
representation and statistical mapping
of the environment, which gets updated
through adaptation and adaptive learning.
I talk about that process.
Really the
the whole.
Bayesian brain hypothesis, free energy
principle is inspired by
cybernetics heavily so Ross Ashby's.
Good.
Regulator theorem
and the law of requisite variety,
which we'll talk about,
was kind of the first talk of systems
having models
and having to model the environment.
So Kristin says inference is actually
quite close to a theory of everything,
including evolution,
consciousness and life itself.
We're not going to go into.
Those bigger. Implications.
That would be at the end of the book
in the last chapter.
But basically this isn't just
a theory about evolution.
Well, it.
Is evolution, but evolution applied
way more broadly.
So quantum
mechanics has an interpretation
that's consistent with this
and bigger problems,
like the fine
tuning of the constants and parameters
that allow for the emergence of life
in the universe, we can actually
probably have the best explanation
for the fine
tuning problem and measurement problem
of quantum mechanics.
With this theory,
we won't talk about it.
But just so you know, next time,
cosmological natural selection
by Lee Smolin is the theory that kind of
addresses the fine tuning problem
from a universal Darwinism perspective
while quantum Darwinism
addresses the measurement problem.
So we will save that for next time,
but feel free to ask questions
about any of those.
So what is this?
Do I have.
This name poetic method naturalism?
I to take that. Out, but.
Next time we'll get into why.
I. Chose that name.
It's actually, it sounds kind of like,
you know, like complex or buzzword
or jargony but there's actually very
practical reasons for having that name.
So this.
Unifying theory, bridges
matter with mind.
So Universal Darwinism gives us
the picture of the open ended complexity.
Gross
that this whole idea is based on the idea
that evolution
keeps producing increasingly complex,
intelligent.
Forms of life.
Excuse me.
So. Yeah, universal Bayesian
ism is the link that kind of connects
those paradigms with
consciousness.
So again, we won't get into that today,
but when you understand
that knowledge is stored
stored in the form of a world model
that a system that models itself
can experience, then we start to get
a better understanding
of what consciousness consciousness is.
It's a it's a mental model.
So it's not a traditional person psychic
theory, even though I know Kristin and.
Levin.
And some of his colleagues
have kind of been flirting
with being Sikhism, this theory would say
that's wrong and it's kind of
reduces
consciousness to something trivial
by saying that it's in everything.
Like a proton is conscious
because it's a triad of quarks
that have to be
in a certain configuration.
So there is some minimal level
of integrated
information that's not enough
to get conscious experience again.
Observer So Safran.
Integrate.
World
modern theory says that you need a model
with spatial temporal
and causal coherence.
I would also argue that it requires
self modeling capacity.
Talk about that a little.
Bit at the end, if anyone's interested.
But this theory is supposed to bridge
mine with cosmic evolution.
So the story starts with the second law.
Daniel, if there's any questions
about that intro, let me know.
Yeah, if. I can just proceed.
Could I ask two questions? From a chat?
Sure.
OK, the first question is from Blue.
Blue wrote Do you think that non-living
autonomous agents
with multiple competing priorities
such as self-driving cars have free will?
If not, what is the defining difference
between these systems and humans?
No, I don't think they have free will.
So adaptive information
is a special type of information.
I do think those things and this is
kind of following Sarah Walker's lead,
who's at Arizona State,
and she's also said five faculty now.
But basically to have self-driving cars,
you first need life.
So anything like a self-driving car
that's like this information
processing system.
If you were to come across a broken.
Down self-driving car on some planet
and you saw that,
you would have to infer that
there was also life there
because life is part of the trajectory
to get to that.
But I wouldn't.
Say that it has free will because it's
just this input output machine
with a defined set of algorithms
and adaptive systems.
Are more flexible.
And they're OK.
So in the next next time we'll talk about
actually the emergence of agency,
which occurs
with the origin apply for Abiogenesis
and you basically.
Because.
This self-organizing system that would be
kind of like the protocell.
Is evolving.
Through a mechanism that
a Darwinian dynamic for self-organization
that will explain a bit.
It builds up information
and at some point there's
a phase transition where the information
that's getting built up in the system
basically gains
what Sarah Walker and Paul Davies
call informational control.
So there's a point where information
actually starts calling the shots. And.
You can see the difference between.
Systems that where.
There is informational. Control.
So living systems and inanimate systems
because for example,
inanimate systems,
their movement can be predicted
with Newton's laws.
So anyone who's taken for sheer physics
probably had to do an exercise
where you're trying to predict
the movement of some macroscopic system
like a ball that gets kicked
or pushed by a gust of wind.
And what you do is.
You are you have to draw out.
All the forces acting on the system,
and then you can understand
where the system is going to go.
With. Life.
You don't need an external force for it
to start, for example, climbing uphill
that's internally generated.
Of course, it's not magic.
The adaptive system, the agent
has stored energy that it's abstracted
from the environment.
So for example, humans
that are eating food
and there's a metabolic process
that's driving this. But.
Still, yeah, with living systems
that where information has causal power,
basically the trajectory of the system
can't be predicted
by these fundamental laws of physics.
So the ball.
Journalist that has been talking about.
This.
Here, his recent article,
which caused a lot of controversy
between like the reductionist
like talking about
free will and agency
and just a lot of confusion around that.
So people like Jerry Coyne
were like trying to shoot it down and
yeah, hopefully I can talk about that.
I guess we'll talk about that
next time because there's a lot of
confusion.
About what we're.
Saying when we say
something has agency or free will.
But his example is if you.
Throw throw a ball and a bird.
Off the tower.
And you. Can predict.
What.
One is going to do, you can't predict
what the other is going to do.
Interestingly, though, I would say that.
The. Birds are completely unpredictable
you can predict
that it's not going to hit the ground.
It's not going to splat on the ground.
It's going to fly away.
You have to understand
the bird in terms of its goals.
So you have to understand
the bird and its environment
and the information
that got built up through evolution.
And then we can start to predict
the bird.
It's statistical behavior.
So inanimate systems, you can pretty much
precisely predict the movement
unless they're chaotic systems,
which is another story.
But with life.
Yeah,
it's not predictable in that same way.
With like low level laws of physics.
But I'm arguing that actually
life is more predictable than we thought.
But you need things like non
equilibrium statistical mechanics
and for example, free energy principle
so you can say that
an organism will try to minimize
free energy or minimize
the difference between its models.
Prediction and reality.
So it will try to minimize
prediction error.
And that's.
A way that we can start to describe
behaviors statistically. So
yeah.
Was there another. Yep.
The second question.
Yeah,
I know I didn't completely answer that,
but that will require
like all of the points that I would
get into in the second topic.
It's a great question. Yeah.
I would have written in a larger
margin if I had more time.
The second question is
from Joseph Clark
who wrote First Complimented your talk
and let you knew
that you were an interesting guy.
So then the question was
how far do you think
the universe can organize itself
and what does that look like?
OK, great.
That's a perfect question
to lead into the next part.
And hopefully by the end of this,
we will have
some sort of answer for that,
which is good because when I started
making the beginning of the presentation,
I was going to get to consciousness
and free will and I ran out of time.
So there's been a lot of talk
about things that I won't get to
but that we will get to.
So the story starts with the second law
so. The second law thermodynamics,
as popularly,
popularly understood, says that systems
naturally become increasingly.
Disordered.
That's really just.
Because of the.
Large scale effects of chance.
So there are.
Many ways to be disordered and there are
relatively fewer ways to be pattern.
So a system
that's this collective of particles.
So this evolving ensemble of.
Particles will.
Naturally
tend to move towards a configuration
that's completely spread out
and mixed up.
There are no energy gradients.
So where it can be extracted,
that's a state of equilibrium
so we are going to use this word
thermodynamic equilibrium
to mean death and disorder.
So life wants to resist the tendency.
Towards. Equilibrium.
It wants to stay ordered.
What's interesting about this
is that it applies to.
All this is kind of like where.
The free energy principle first since
Bayesian brained hypothesis,
it frames everything this way.
So I thought it.
Was a.
Good way to kind of frame it here
is that you start with the second rule
in any conceivable system,
any ordered system, for it
to continue to
persist has to resist this tendency.
So basically.
Schrodinger the guy everybody knows
from quantum mechanics in the in the cat
thought experiment,
he wrote a book called
What Is Life in the Forties, and
basically kind of solved this paradox,
like if there's a second rule
and things become more disordered,
then what's with life
and what's with the biosphere
and all this complexity
that we see around us.
And he explained.
Actually, Boltzmann
explained this before him.
But Boltzmann.
Said a lot to contradict. This as well.
Or just didn't
follow this to its implications.
But Schrodinger explained that.
Open. Systems.
By. Feeding off
free energy in the environment.
So free energy is just energy
that you can extract work from.
So it's ordered
energy as opposed to energy
that's been dissipated
in the form of heat.
You can expect energy
useful energy from that energy.
It's still there.
It's just spread out
and it's you can't harness it.
Collecting it would cost more than you
get out of it.
So Schrödinger.
Explained that.
If. A system can get free energy,
which he called negative entropy
or energy, Nagin peace
was called by someone later.
So to understand.
How ordered system stay ordered,
you basically need to understand
that they have to
constantly be extracting free energy
from the environment.
The moment that they can't
extract more free
energy is the moment that the system dies
and decays to equilibrium.
So basically
the second law is not violated by life
because.
In this.
Effort to stay far from equilibrium.
In. Life, it keeps extracting
that ordered free energy
and keeps dissipating it as heat.
So so it's basically exporting entropy
into the environment.
So the. Order.
That is maintained
is paid for by the dissipated energy
which come becomes thermal entropy.
So there are multiple.
Definitions of entropy.
So you have thermal entropy,
which is heat entropy
and then statistical entropy.
Which explains. Thermal entropy.
But it has.
A. Broader domain of application.
So you can talk about
shuffling a deck of cards
and you can talk about like
statistical entropy increasing
if the deck is ordered and it starts
becoming mixed, accepting the shuffling.
But the deck of cards.
The thermal entropy
isn't changing much at all.
So there's different types of entropy.
There's also information entropy,
which has to do.
With the
the number of.
Messages that can be sent across
the channel instead of.
The number.
Of states that a system can be in,
the number of micro states
without changing the
macro state, macro state. Or.
The kind of collective properties.
Of this system.
And there's a really neat
relationship between statistical entropy
and information entropy,
which I won't talk about here.
It was really fleshed out by each Jane's.
Yeah.
But yeah, so information
in entropy might go hand in hand.
Just to. Give a little more context.
Before we get into the details,
David Deutsch in his great TEDTalk.
Called.
After billions of years of anatomy,
the universe is waking up as if
to speak of a cosmic war.
It's war between monotony and novelty,
between status and creativity.
And in this war,
our side is not destined to lose.
If we choose to apply.
Our unique capacity to create explanatory
knowledge, we could. Win.
So that's very different
than Brian Greene story.
And it kind of gets at
the second question that was asked there.
How how.
Far can this complexity increase go?
And so this kind of foreshadows
that maybe it doesn't have a limit.
And that seems you know,
most people think that would go against
the second half of thermodynamics.
We're going to see why
that's not necessarily true.
But you can also see this cosmic war
as this fight between water
versus disordered life versus entropy
and knowledge
versus uncertainty or ignorance.
But is life's battle against disorder
good.
Versus evil or yin and yang?
So I'm going to kind of argue
that these two things kind of have this.
You can describe their relationship
as causally dependent,
and it's kind of like this dialectic
between life
and disorder.
And it is through this sort of.
Interaction that creates progress.
So we have some Eastern ideas
mentioned again.
But when.
I was writing the book, a friend. That.
Practices
Buddhism called me and told me about this
interdependent, polarizing idea,
which I thought was really.
Cool so we're going to come up with this,
what we call.
Popper's principle, which is problems
create progress.
We're going to see that this problem. Of.
Entropy, that this tendency towards
decay is what actually.
Forces systems to.
Evolve.
Basically, it forces them to search.
What's called the.
Configuration space
for the phase, space for the state, space
to find configurations that are good
at extracting energy and that allows it
to stay far from equilibrium
so we're going to have some figures soon.
So this stuff that's kind of abstract
becomes a little bit more concrete.
Just.
Out of respect to the earlier request,
how about you check the time and feel
then how fast you'd like to continue
however much you want to present.
And then
if you want to take any questions,
but first, just check the time and let.
Just how I didn't
I didn't.
Notice when we started.
So about how long have I been going?
I would say five 0 minutes.
Really?
OK, how long. Can we go.
We can go another
99 minutes. OK,
I'll try to go through it
little bit faster.
But yeah, so.
But if we use all the time.
I told you yesterday that I was feeling.
Oh, I had a sore. Throat
and this shorter.
It's better
today. I'm hopped up on cold medicine.
I'm sure I'm
going to pay for it tomorrow.
But yeah, if we use all the time
with questions, that would be good.
So in our everyday experience
experience, things
don't naturally become ordered
unless someone intervenes.
Rooms get messier, buildings or road
so we already talked about this
Schrodinger's solution,
so we can think of life as a game.
So life has always been playing a game
against the second law of thermodynamics.
There is another narrative that I won't.
Go into,
but life is also an energy flow channel.
So life
by existing
in computing and trying to say.
Librium.
Is also increasing entropy.
Actually, the universe of life
will increase entropy at a faster
rate in a universe without life,
which is pretty interesting.
So it's again,
not necessarily that life is like
battling against entropy,
and in many ways it increases entropy.
But there's also this story.
I guess what it's trying to battle
is the tendency towards disorder.
So it depends on what type of entropy
you're talking about.
So the challenge in the game of life,
which applies to you
as well as other simpler adaptive systems
is to resist that tendency.
So this gives. Life
a goal. For Teleology.
So Trilogy was associated
with kind of this mystical thing, but
basically while we're seeing
that Teleology is just agency, it's.
Just a result goal.
Oriented behavior as a result of
the information that's been.
Accumulated over.
Evolution. So Teleology.
The book.
Tries to naturalize ideology
and just say that
they're these goal oriented systems
that behave different.
Because.
They are acquiring information
through Darwinian evolution.
So life has to attract free energy.
That's how it stays in the game of life.
And to extract free energy, it's
not a simple task.
So the.
Computational task of extracting
free energy
requires
that the system acquire information
about its environment,
otherwise it can't find energy.
It also.
Requires
that the system model its environment.
So the information is creating this
predictive model, this generative model.
And it is
that model.
That allows it
to continuously find free energy.
So we will explain that life strategy
as it searches
through a configuration space
for solutions to the problem of survival
through trial and error, search
variation
and selection so we know about evolution.
There's this genetic variation
in natural selection,
and we're going to argue that that
process, that mechanism is much broader.
The evolutionary mechanism
is actually the mechanism
of the scientific method
and of adaptive learning.
And that mechanism is also a process that
accumulates evidence based knowledge.
So it's also a process
a Bayesian in France.
We're going explain. Why.
So here we have those different
mechanisms with different names.
So it's not included.
Here.
But so if life is a game,
there are levels to this game
and the levels we're going to see
are these evolutionary transitions.
Every time life graduates to this.
More.
Complex hierarchical system, like when
single celled organisms come together
to form a multicellular organism
and multicellular organisms come together
to form communities like societies.
That you can view.
These evolutionary transitions as as life
graduating to.
A new level so.
We're going to talk about
how adaptive information
gets built up through evolution.
And we're calling that knowledge.
It's nice to have that word knowledge,
because this process
of an adaptive system
acquiring this information
is actually reducing its uncertainty.
About the environment.
So it's it's reducing its ignorance
about all the ways the surrounding world
could potentially surprise it.
So knowledge is a nice word.
Some philosophers.
Like old school philosophers.
Might have issue with that
because in some teaching psych
knowledge is something that conscious
beings with awareness have.
But we're calling any adaptive
information knowledge, and it's got
more of a technical definition
because knowledge is that information,
which reduces uncertainty.
And you can actually quantify
this process of evolution.
And Terence, in has talked a lot
about how you can do that with
information measures.
So just.
To explain this, why is knowledge
something that matters?
Like does it have causal. Power.
Or is it all just this this billiard
ball universe where it's like these.
Particles bumping into.
Each other and you can basically use
fundamental laws of physics
to describe like the trajectory
of all of the particles in the universe.
This is saying no, that the information
gets built up through
evolution, has causal power
such that these systems start to behave
in ways that are different
than what would be predicted from
something like Newton's laws.
So we also have this process
of anti accretion
that Sarah Walker likes to talk about,
but anti so anti accretion is.
Basically we're familiar with.
Planets pulling in matter.
So bodies like asteroids because
gravity pulls matter in naturally.
But anti accretion is
when a planet is ejecting matter.
And in many cases.
What well so the only.
Time we really see anti accretion.
Is. When you have
a planet with life on it. So
right now
bits of biosphere.
So humans in space rockets are being sent
to other celestial bodies
so that's a form of anti accretion
sending up satellites.
You won't see a satellite get sent out
if you see that in the universe.
Like.
You're looking at some other solar system
and you see a body sent out
and put into orbit from a planet,
that's an indication that life is there.
That's a bio signature.
So she says that integration requires
comprehension, specifically the existence
of physical systems
with knowledge of Newton's laws.
So so what is it all mean?
It means we need knowledge. To.
Keep us out of thermodynamics.
Equilibrium
so how do we acquire knowledge?
Science is the most.
Is. The most salient example.
Of the causal.
Power of knowledge. So science
has eradicated lethal diseases,
built a global communication
network called the Internet
and created weapons of apocalyptic power.
It's not always.
Good, this power of knowledge, but.
We see that there's something
about the scientific method
which is efficient at
accumulating knowledge.
So we're going to talk about why,
and that's where we get into Karl Popper
and evolutionary epistemology.
So we know knowledge is important.
Karl Popper says we're always faced
with practical problems
and out of these gross, sometimes
theoretical problems for we try to solve
some of our problems
by proposing theories.
So if.
Popper stresses
that all of science starts
with a problem, either theoretical or.
Practical.
And it is that. Problem.
That forces us to seek out a solution
so we can already see why
this principle
that I've called Popper's principle
says that problems create progress.
So some of these.
Theories that we make to try to solve
our problems will be wrong.
There will be errors.
But the idea with science
is that those errors get filtered out
by a process of testing your theories
and a peer review process
which gives criticism.
So knowledge is really.
For knowledge for us to know that some.
Piece of information is knowledge.
It really needs to be tested.
And we call that evidence based knowledge
or evidence based information.
So that's really the only true
kind of knowledge because you don't know
if something is true until you test it.
For example,
the world doesn't look.
Round from a naive perspective.
It looks. Flat.
So for example,
someone who had the first idea
and I'm sure it was before anybody
famous, we knew someone had this idea
and probably people blew it off.
But some things that are true
about reality are not immediate,
immediately apparent from like sensory
observation, from sense data
so we really need to test our theories
if we are going to be sure about them.
So what Popper found out was
the scientific method is an algorithm.
We call that algorithm
conjecture and refutation.
And basically
this is the method of hypothesis testing.
So you have a problem
you believe can be solved.
You make an informed guess, are sure to
see if your theory can be refuted,
prove false by testing its predictions.
So people have pointed out.
Like John. Campbell.
First in
that science is a process of inference.
So he recognizes statistical patterns
and trends in nature
that we can use to make
increasingly accurate predictions.
It would not be an accurate thing
to say that the function
or purpose of scientists
to generate predictive knowledge
and we can
characterize that as process
of inference, which basically means
that scientists draw logical conclusions
about the way the world works
based on evidence
based information acquired in the past,
but with an ever present awareness
that the information can
and will lead to.
To new.
Conclusions and deeper understanding.
So when we recognize this,
we also have to recognize that
all of our models will have uncertainty
so we should never think that our models.
Right?
Every model is going to be proved
wrong in some way.
But through the scientific process,
the idea is that we get closer
and closer to truth,
so we can never reach perfect truth.
But in this model you.
Can actually get closer to it.
So in some senses, it's different
than like post-modernist philosophy
that says there is no objective truth,
there is an objective truth
but we can never
know it, but we can get closer to it.
So once Popper.
Understood that knowledge, the knowledge
generating mechanism behind science
success was conjecture and reputation,
he realized that human learning, which
begins at birth, continues to that uses
the same problem solving algorithm.
Although the developmental.
Psychology literature
called the method, trial and error.
So because life is constantly
presenting us with new challenges
such as the need to get from one place
to another problem that inspires babies
to learn to walk, we must constantly
try out new behavioral solutions.
We can think of these actions as guesses
about how to survive or if you prefer
experiments in evading equilibrium
or predictions for persist
and they will often fail.
So. This is damned in its idea of life
exploring this design space.
We're going to talk about how it does
so through evolution.
We're still talking about science here.
And adaptive learning.
On abstract level,
we can imagine a certain
practical problem
as a challenge, one with a solution
that exists somewhere out there
in the space of possibilities,
just waiting to be found by someone
sufficiently motivated and clever.
It may take some time,
but if the possibilities space,
the space of possible
solutions is continuously.
Explored in an efficient way,
eventually a solution will be discovered.
So excuse me.
Trial and error learning explores
the solution. Space
so just to give you a clear.
Example of how adaptive learning
is kind of this form
of hypothesis testing.
So whenever we have a problem.
In life and we don't know the correct
solution to a problem in advance,
we naturally begin
with those potential solutions
that are closer to our starting point
in the solution space we're sampling.
So for example.
If a baby reaches for its bottle.
And barely.
Misses, it'll just its behavior slightly,
which minimizes
the chances of making an error.
So. Our instincts may nudges
in the general direction of a solution,
but the instinct alone is not.
Enough.
We have to try out.
What you could call.
A behavioral conjecture,
and when it fails, we try something new.
So that's kind of like a new theory,
and it's essentially the.
Old one, but with a little. Twist.
And if that behavioral solution
is remembered, then it's it's.
Stored for future.
Use, ready to be repeated,
but also adapted if necessary,
but in humans.
So the baby example reaching for the
bottle, let's say it misses the bottle.
It won't get a reward signal,
it won't get a little surge of dopamine.
So if it corrects and it gets closer,
it gets a little reward signal.
This is reinforcement learning.
But basically this adaptive learning
process is a process of making theories
and eliminating those theories
that our ears.
So Popper saw.
That scientific knowledge.
And the.
Evolutionary process were also connected.
So not only is science adaptive learning,
both of those things are extensions
of the evolutionary process.
So he says in science,
theories are highly competitive
we discuss them critically,
we test them, and we eliminate the series
which we judged to be less
good in solving the problems
which we wish to solve.
So only the.
Best theories, those which are most fit,
survive in the struggle.
This is the way science grows.
So that's kind of nice, like showing you
really how
this is an evolutionary process,
not only is
science, not illusionary process,
the converse is true.
Evolution is a scientific process.
So it is clear.
This is another quote.
It is clear
that this view of the progress of science
is very similar to Darwin's
view of natural selection,
by the way, of the elimination
of the. Bit.
Of the errors in the evolution of life,
the errors,
the attempts to adaptation,
which is a trial and error process.
Analogously,
science works by trial theory making
and by the elimination of errors.
I. Might pause in a second just to see
if everybody understands this,
but I have a few more slides.
So evolutionary algorithms.
Also.
Use this mechanism,
but it's called generate and test.
So I didn't mention this.
The mechanism of evolution
is variation in selection.
So we have these algorithms
that are equivalent
conjecture and refutation trial and error
variation in selection
we also have generate and test.
So in machine learning, evolutionary.
Algorithms.
Have this method. Of.
Generating. Tests.
Possible solutions are generated
into an actual solution is found
and these solutions accumulate
in some memory store
while the errors are filtered out
and forgotten
in science.
The solutions are theories or models that
actually predicts the natural phenomena
and the.
Successful ones.
Accumulate in peer
reviewed journals and. Textbooks.
So we see that
these processes are equivalent.
We're actually going to see that it's
this Bayesian process that adaptation.
Is. Also a process.
Of the model.
Of the organism becoming optimized,
decreasing it's prediction error
so that can more efficiently extract
free energy
from an edge to stay ordered.
So we get this principle
that all evolutionary processes
are learning processes, and all learning
processes are evolutionary processes.
Conrad Lorenz, Nobel Prize
winning zoologist.
Was also a.
Pioneer of evolutionary epistemology,
and he made this statement Life is
a cognitive process.
So if this is true and there's
this functional equivalence
between the mechanisms
driving evolution, learning and science.
And that.
Implies that adaptation.
Or the.
Genetic information that
corresponds
to those physical adaptations.
Are equivalent.
Is equivalent to scientific knowledge,
they're actually the same thing.
So to kind of make this relationship
clear,
biological adaptation
represents knowledge of the environment
and the knowledge
we acquire through learning and science
reflects adaptation to the environment.
So we see that there's no meaningful
distinction between adaptive information
and scientific knowledge.
Both allow life to predict
an uncertain world control matter, train
chaos and construct order from disorder.
So the very same property
that is responsible for organic matter
leaving the planet in spaceships.
So this entire creation is the same
property that allows
organisms to climb uphill, seemingly
defying the force of gravity.
Of course.
The laws of physics aren't
violated in any.
Way, but.
Living systems are not constrained
by the laws of physics,
the way inanimate systems are
so some examples of dolphin
streamlined design,
which is a product of the information
storage genome, contains the.
Knowledge of hydrodynamics.
An eagle swing design contains
the knowledge of aerodynamics.
Not only can we be certain
that engineers see knowledge
in these functional structures,
there should be little doubt
that they inspired
our machines.
And without that information,
I don't think we would have come
to those inventions,
at least not any time soon.
Camouflage
on an organism represents
knowledge of the environment.
So kind of bridging this.
Idea of evolutionary cosmology,
that evolution builds up knowledge,
and that science is an extension
of the evolutionary process.
Making a bridge.
Between that and Bayesian inference
requires this
relationship between adaptation
and statistical correlation.
So physicist Carlo Rivoli, which who has
gotten really interested in explaining.
How. This information that underlies
agency, that behavior that we see
with living
systems, gets built up through evolution
he wrote a great essay,
won the Foundational Questions Institute
essay contest.
A few years ago, but.
This work was based on the work of David
Wolpert and Artem
Kinski, Artemis Kuczynski,
and basically shows
how this adaptation
builds up information in the system.
That information
is really statistical correlation
between the organism and its environment.
So here's the simplest example.
It's a bacterium performing chemo taxes.
So a bacteria.
So chemo tax is basically
a bacterium will swim
in the direction of food
and swim away from toxins.
So basically it's detecting this chemical
gradient that follows.
But so we can see in this example
and this isn't the case for all species,
but you can imagine that
a bacterium that swings to the left
when nutrients are on.
The left.
Prospers compared to a bacterium
that swims at random.
So with this
behavior
where it's swimming towards food,
that is the.
Product of a chance mutation.
So in some sense it's an accident.
But when it discovers that solution.
That organism
is more likely to reproduce.
So that solution gets retained
in the population,
it gets sort of frozen, hardwired in.
And so the process of adaptation
is a process.
That builds up a.
Statistical correlation between.
The system, the agent.
And its environment.
And so that shared this correlation
represents mutual information.
So mutual information is information
that's shared
between the environment
and the organism. And
just to
explain that a little bit more,
this correlation.
Basically as this correlation gets built
up, it's creating predictive knowledge.
So. John Maynard Smith
cites Fred Dread Ski,
who did kind of the pioneering
work applying Shannon's information
theory to try to quantify evolution.
So Jet Ski argues
that if some variable is correlated
with the second variable, B,
then we can say that B carries
information about A, for example,
if the occurrence of rain is correlated
with a particular cloud,
then the type of cloud tells us
whether it would rain.
So that's from a great essay
called Concepts of Information Biology.
So we can see that you have this little.
Rhyming equation here.
Adaptation equals statistical correlation
equals mutual information.
And because.
That shared. Information.
Allows the.
Organism
to predict its environment better,
this process is also a process
of model optimization.
So the predictive model of the organism
as it adapts,
starts to become more accurate.
And so this whole process can be seen
as a free energy minimization process.
Of. Course,
that's information theoretic free energy.
It's the free energy of, for instance,
principle.
We're not talking about thermodynamic
free energy.
We once asked a questioner
gets confused about that,
let me know.
But it's basically those.
Things are related and it's something
that's not mentioned in.
Minimizing.
Information theoretic free energy,
which is just minimizing
the prediction error of your model
is what allows the organism
to minimize environmental free energy.
So by acquiring information, producing
information theoretic energy, allows
the organism to extract energy
and reduce thermodynamic free energy,
it minimizes the free energy
and the environment
converts it into entropy.
So we kind of see how this is fitting
into universal Bayesian ism.
As it becomes more correlated,
it gains information about its nature
and therefore.
Becomes
a better. Predictor of that niche.
So that's what adaptation is.
It's the genome of the species
accumulating information that reduces
the average organisms, uncertainty
regarding the environment.
So the.
Genome is a knowledge
repository of solutions to environmental.
Challenges that allows.
An organism with no brain and no mind
to anticipate events in the environment.
So in this theory, as I mentioned before,
consciousness comes later,
it comes with self
modeling capacity. And.
A bacterium
would be kind of a zombie agent.
It would have agency
and it would move with purpose.
But that is not enough.
For the. Mind or at least mind
defined as consciousness.
If you want to say
that mind is just information processing,
then yes, there is mind in these systems
but that's very different than saying
that the system
has a subjective experience
in a first person perspective
that will come in the next talk.
But it's it's harder
so. That information stored
memory is integrated into a discourse
or predictive model that determines
the causal control systems, behavioral.
Repertoire.
Or the full range of behaviors
an organism is capable of.
And it is this mapping of sensory inputs,
motor outputs that makes the organism
move in ways that we normally associate
with mind or consciousness.
First in integration article says
all biological processes can be construed
as performing some form of inference.
I think I already read that.
But the free.
Energy principle for those familiar,
we've already explained it.
But the.
Bayesian brain hypothesis and the free
energy principle are the same thing.
The difference is that the free energy
principle applies to.
All. Other adaptive systems, where
the other one is just focusing on brains.
But first realize that this
is a model and a process that
applies to
any system that's trying to resist
the tendency towards disorder.
So any system.
To stay to continue persisting longer
than we would expect, naturally
it must engage in Bayesian like learning
to deal with environmental uncertainty.
How much time do I have left?
Roughly
still more than enough.
To go on.
I'm definitely more than halfway through.
I'd say I'm two thirds of the way here.
So John Campbell has this great
paper called Universal Darwinism
as a process of Bayesian inference
that I kept coming across
as I was trying to understand
non equilibrium, thermodynamics
and information theory.
Yeah, I should say actually
I should have gotten the books showed.
You each book, but there's a great book
called The Origin and Nature of Life
on Earth.
By Stanford Institute's
Eric Smith. And here Moritz.
Moritz was a professor of mine.
Eric is a friend that we would have
these foundations of the mind
guilt.
It was like a consciousness club
that would meet at the Krasno Institute
where I got my Ph.D. And.
So their book.
The Origin of Life on the Origin of.
Life in Chapter eight.
Actually
gets into this information theory.
And this
this Bayesian inference and describes
the origin of life and the evolution.
Of life as.
A process of Bayesian model selection.
And so that was kind of what connected
non equilibrium
statistical mechanics to these,
to this Bayesian brain hypothesis.
And I realized that,
you know, these theories were kind of
converging on the same ideas.
So John Campbell.
Wrote this paper in 2016.
He says Bayesian
inference is an algorithm
for the accumulation of evidence
based knowledge.
This algorithm is now seem to operate
over a wide range of evolutionary
processes, including natural selection,
the evolution of mental models
and cultural evolutionary processes,
notably including science itself.
So when
we say that evolution is a process
of Bayesian model selection, in the book
I mentioned with Eric
and it's actually characterized evolution
as an inference engine,
we're basically saying
that when organisms that aren't
fit get weeded out,
that's basically models
that aren't predictive
getting eliminated.
So the organisms that persist
are the models that were able
to predict the environment best.
So inference and prediction
are kind of the same thing
since the word inferences
they're not scary.
I guess. So
just to make this point
a little more clear,
since nature is complex
and intrinsically unpredictable,
the model of an organism is at some point
guaranteed to fail
when reality surprises it
with the unexpected.
So and that's what the free energy
principle is about, minimizing surprises.
The same thing is minimizing
prediction error.
So an organism gets eaten by a predator,
a baby fails
to reach his bottle, a scientific theory
fails to explain new data
basically,
when any of these things happens,
it means that the model used to predict
reality is not completely accurate.
It contains a certain amount
of prediction error
and needs to be corrected.
So what's the solution?
Try something new.
The old model worked
well enough up to that point,
so don't ditch it
just varied a bit and see if it performs
better.
If it does not reduce surprise,
eliminate that variant and try again.
If. Prediction errors reduce or replace
the old model with the new one.
So that becomes the reigning theory
and the design template for new variants.
We based upon
when a model has been updated
in this way due to natural selection,
adaptive learning
or experimental testing,
we can say that knowledge
has been acquired
and environmental uncertainty reduced.
So. Here we have an image.
I should say that Infinity Maps German
software mapping company helped me
create these images Oliver Wagner.
I have to give a big thanks to him.
This image has.
A little bit more going on
than I would want.
Right now, but you could see that
basically
this represents two
different mechanisms. For.
Learning and adaptation.
So this one on the top
that we're going to talk about first.
Is the normal.
Competitive evolution,
sort of Darwinian survival of the.
Fittest
while this.
Mechanism over here
is the mechanism of self-organization.
So let's first
talk about the normal type of evolution
where you're with and show that.
How. This process of evolution
that works, the variation in selection
actually
generates predictive information and
creates.
A model which is
which.
Encodes knowledge. Of the.
Biologically relevant
regularities in the environment.
So first we have this.
This is a.
Bacterium over here.
And so.
This is the simplest. Model.
You have an organism
that's an embodied theory or a best guess
about how to stay far from equilibrium.
So evolutionary physiology sees
organisms themselves as embodied theory.
So evolution is basically testing
these different models.
So it basically reproduces
and we know that
because there are going to be
errors in
in that process,
the genome will get changed
slightly and you will get.
A. Generation of progeny that.
All are.
Slightly different they have slightly
different configurations.
Some of these configurations
will be better
at extracting energy and predicting
the environment than others.
And the ones that
are good at predicting the
environment, they get filtered out
by natural selection.
So here we see design.
For is the winning.
Design because it's the best predictor
and it's the best predictor
because it's
the best attractor of energy.
And so that design
that that organism gets to reproduce.
And then you have another generation
of designs that are slightly different
and this process is an iterative process,
just like science.
And. Hypothesis testing.
So over generations
you will start to get designs that. Are.
Better adapted to the environment,
which we've explain means that
they will be more correlated
with the environment.
And being more correlated means
being a better predictor
so the knowledge
that's left over after this process
is the adaptive information
stored in genetic material
that produces environmental certainty.
And you see it this process. Will.
Ultimately lead to the evolution
towards the best possible design.
So it's it's an optimization.
A lot of people don't think
that evolution is optimizing anything.
There's been this
kind of philosophy that evolution does.
Just good enough.
But we actually see that
in terms of the computation
that it does
to stay far from equilibrium,
that it's actually optimized
for being almost
maximally efficient
with its use of energy.
The approach is something close
to what's called the Landauer limit,
which David Wolpert
it SFI is written about.
But life is much more efficient
with computation in terms of energy
supply needed
compared to all of our technology.
So the human brain can do
solve problems
that even our best systems can't solve.
And it does so running. On.
The equivalent of one.
Household light bulb.
So we'll come back
to this self-organization process.
Oh, well, actually.
We'll get into that right now.
So this is the normal.
Process that we think about
when we think about evolution generating
knowledge, predictive knowledge.
And so that's called phylogenetic
learning.
Phylogenetic refers
to these like generations.
So the learning is generational.
The organisms don't really learn.
Because they. Don't have brains.
They're not able to.
Update their. Model in real time.
So learning is at.
The level of the population.
And for learning to occur,
organisms have to die before brains.
Basically, you have to have this
competition
for there to be a learning process
however.
There's also.
Self-Organization when these organisms.
Don't compete, but.
Actually find a configuration,
find it, discover
collective configuration through their.
Somewhat random.
Interactions with each other.
And when they find this collective
configuration
through trial and error,
basically the configurations
that are better at attracting energy
will be the ones.
That are.
Retained.
So Donald Campbell.
Father Evolutionary Epistemology.
Explained.
This process, this evolutionary process
by which self-organization
works as blind variation
and selective retention,
or we can think of it as selection
for persistence or stability.
So fitness kind of
here's the Dawkins quote.
I think I come out where Richard Dawkins
said, Darwin's.
Survival. Of the fittest is.
Really
just.
More specific instance of a more general
law of survival of the stable.
So when we think about being fit
at the beginning we're talking about
just being stable,
being able to find energy.
If you can't do that,
it doesn't matter whether you have agents
that you're competing with or not.
Because if you can't get energy,
it doesn't matter if there are other
people competing for it,
then you won't survive. So
you don't need.
Replication with variation to evolve.
That's
what this is, this model is saying.
And Stuart Kaufman from the Santa
Fe Institute. Has.
Been talking about the importance
of this marriage between
Darwinian evolution
and self-organization.
But basically.
Because.
There's not this replication process,
this is how evolution occurs.
So you have a system that's.
A collection. Of components, parts.
These parts can be molecules
or they can be agents.
And when these molecules are pushed
far from equilibrium by flow of energy
of course, humans are eating food
and metabolizing energy,
so they're being powered
by energy flows as well.
The system blindly explores.
Various configurations in the space
with possible designs via trial and.
Error.
So this system will move through
a series of configurations.
And those.
Configurations that allow the system
to extract sufficient energy
to stay out of equilibrium
will get retained.
While the configurations that don't allow
for energy extraction.
Will.
Get filtered out, the system will collapse and have to try a new configuration.
Or it will just.
Revert to the previous stable
configuration and it will continue
trying to explore
that configuration space.
I. Should have said, here's
a good example.
Here's
a depiction of this configuration space.
We're talking about life
exploring the design space. So
basically you have a designer
configuration and.
Then.
You get these different
this exploration. Of.
Different configurations
that are very close
to the configuration
you started out with.
So I was thinking about giving a talk
on the origin of life, but I couldn't
get into all this cool Bayesian stuff.
That's
what the first part of the book is about.
What's really interesting is that
we're finding that self-organization,
as mentioned, is a Darwinian process.
So there's actually a name for this
disruptive adaptation, and it shows that.
This.
Relation towards these more stable
configurations dissipate more energy.
When this happens at the level of
organisms that we're talking about,
it shouldn't be surprising that
it dissipates more energy
because basically.
As. The organism evolves to be better
at extracting energy, all that energy
it's extracting to maintain
far from equilibrium
is being converted into thermal entropy.
So all self-organizing processes
are really dissipated.
Adaptation
processes. At different. Levels.
So this process, philosophers would say,
is multiply realizable.
So this process can happen
at different scales.
And that's exactly what we see.
Like right here, the same process.
So you would have a society like
exploring different governance systems
and it doesn't know
which governance system is going to work
the best beforehand. It tries it.
If it doesn't work well.
Like the fall of Rome.
It will collapse
and then it will reassemble.
So just to wrap up the.
Origin of life.
So we have this process of disruptive
adaptation, and if it's being pushed
by the full of energy
and it's doing this process here
where it's finding increasingly
stable configurations,
collective configurations.
Then basically what.
Will emerge is an auto catalytic
said, we'll define that later.
But basically.
It's.
An I'm
losing a lot of cancer for philosophy.
I was going to say.
It's the.
Beginning of an auto poetic agent.
So like a self maintaining agent
in its simplest form is a chemical system
that produces.
Outputs.
Which are then fed back into the system
so that the system can self amplify.
It's basically creating all of
the molecules that it needs to grow.
And it's thought that this process
occurred.
That the auto.
Catalytic asset is kind of the precursor
for the first cell.
So it's kind of like a protocell.
And it was thought to occur around
hydrothermal vents.
Which are under water, volcanoes.
There's all this energy.
Flowing up from the, the,
the hot core running through.
Geochemical energy,
and there's these rocky pores
in the rocks around
hydrothermal vents,
which provides something like.
A membrane, like a lipid membrane
to hold.
The components in a mark off
blankets for the pores in the.
Rocks or.
The mark off
blanket for the auto catalytic set.
And Eric
Smith and Horowitz showed that basically
feeding off inorganic inputs.
Like.
Carbon molecules, like not
not anything, not organic chemistry,
where it's like life, which is like.
Simple.
Carbon, hydrogen and oxygen feeding off.
Those inputs.
Basically the metabolic.
Process,
it's called a reverse Krebs cycle.
So that. Process.
Allowed the.
First
auto catalytic set to continuously self.
Amplify
through this through.
This process.
So if this. Process is allowed to.
Continue.
Further self-organization
may eventually lead to the emergence
of an organic computer
that can process, integrate
and store information about the world.
So what dissipated adaptation.
Is doing is as it's.
Doing this blind variation
and selective retention
process, and it's
finding more stable configurations.
Those more.
Stable configurations are.
Also predictive. Of the environment.
So this disruptive adaptation process
is this auto catalytic asset.
Modeling.
The surrounding energy landscape.
So I'm arguing that
this is where modeling begins.
It even begins before what we call life
like self-replicating life
and its dissipated adaptation,
which is a process
of modeling the the energy
in the environment, the energy.
Sources
so. This
isn't just one continuous process.
There are these leaps
that are phase transitions.
Basically,
we've heard of phase transitions in
physics and chemistry.
Courses.
Where you have like.
Water.
Being heated up
and in transitioning into a gas
or the reverse,
when a gas becomes frozen,
you get a state of order that emerges.
These.
Transitions. Towards.
These configurations
that are good at extracting energy.
Those have also been characterized
as phase transitions.
So Eric Smith,
who I mentioned before, and Harold Moritz
they have this phase transition
theory of life.
Which basically
explains how.
Information gains.
Control in.
These. Systems.
In Sarah Walker and Paul Davies
work on this, basically show that
through this process, the blind variation
and selective retention information
gets built up in this auto catalytic set.
And at some point there's what they
call algorithmic takeover
or informational
control, and the system becomes an agent
that can start to steer and control
itself.
In. Ways
that wouldn't be predicted by physics. So
living system is very much like we didn't
talk about dissipated structures.
But like.
Tornadoes, whirlpools,
those things emerge
to dissipate an energy gradient.
Living things because of the.
Process of metabolism.
We are this cycling system,
this thermodynamic
energetic loop.
But was going to see that
OK, so yeah, we are like the storm,
but we do.
Have. Control over this.
We're a storm with control.
So it doesn't really make sense.
Going back to Sam Harris's quote that
you are the storm, you do not control it.
It's literally.
The information that gets built up
through evolution that allows
us being this dissipated structure
like a.
Storm.
To start controlling its own behavior.
So the last.
Part is just an argument for that.
Second question,
why should complexity increase as.
We. Know that this evolutionary process
where you build up this model?
So we would think that this after
these generations of evolution,
this organism is going to be
well adapted to its environment.
But we know that adaptation
doesn't mean becoming more complex so.
So. Sharks and crocodiles are cited
as species
that haven't evolved much at all
in many millions of years.
Cave fish
actually evolved to become more simple.
So basically fish with eyes yet isolated
and like an underground environment
where there was no
need for sunlight.
And so.
Basically.
Fish like processing light like ice.
Didn't have any survival advantage.
So basically fish lost their eyes
over many
generations of evolution
becoming simpler.
So if that's true, why.
Should evolution increase complexity
the answer to that,
it comes from this understanding
that evolutionary cosmology
says that a species adapted to a niche
is like a scientific theory.
Being tested for viability,
species will evolve
not to become increasingly complex.
But to match.
The complexity of the environment.
A sort of simple.
Solution to the thermodynamic problem
of staying far from equilibrium.
So Einstein
famously said a theory should be.
As simple as possible, but no simpler.
The same can be said about an organism.
You want it to be.
As simple as possible.
While it.
Accomplishes
its task of extracting energy.
It has to be complex enough to be.
Able to extract energy
in a competitive environment.
But a bacterium.
Doesn't have to do
it, doesn't need intelligence.
Any extra information
processing, higher level cognition.
Would. Be energy wasted.
That could.
Be energy that
allows it to stay far from equilibrium
for longer and replicate more.
So it's not the case
that everything will
evolve towards higher complexity.
But the.
Reason that we do. Get.
Increasingly complex species. Over.
Evolutionary time
in a way that I'm saying is inevitable.
So there is a progressive evolutionary
process that leads to higher forms.
It has to do with nature emergent.
So so basically a species will evolve
to become as complex
as its niche, as its environmental niche.
But there will be increasingly complex
niches that.
Emerge for.
Reasons that will be explained. But.
I will pause there
before I get to that,
which will be what we end on.
There are no other questions right now.
So if anyone does have questions,
how about they can feel free to ask it
during this last section
give you a second to catch your breath.
I know it's been a.
Ton of information.
Like my goal is that
since this is being recorded
it will be something that's up.
Hopefully I've cited enough.
Literature.
That people can explore
this stuff themselves and see that like,
OK, it's not this guy that's like.
Kook. Claiming
to have like a theory of everything.
This isn't my theory.
It's a synthesis that's emerging and
really this story has been there
for quite some time,
and the cybernetics pioneers,
actually a lot of them,
where you could call them
like cosmic cardiologists,
a lot of them did see this
continual increase in complexity.
Of course, there's nothing mystical
about it or supernatural about it.
It's a mechanistic process
that doesn't change the fact that nature
seems to have these built.
In goals.
That emerge from the fundamental laws
and constants, the parameters,
the fine tuning,
but it's a completely natural,
progressive,
teleological, evolutionary process,
and so I'll just
end, you know, this is just finishing up.
It's along those same lines.
So that's good
questions can come after this.
I know it's been quite a lot
so I will just try to.
Sum this up simply.
So two important
principles from cybernetics
these came from Ross Ashby,
who also created the principle
of self-organization,
which was really the first time
people took self-organization seriously.
So we think of complexity science
as being the science
of self-organization,
but it really goes back to cybernetics.
I think the term
I think might have talked about it,
but it was Ross
Ashby who tried to give it up,
make it a principle
and a formalized concept.
So there are.
These two concepts that really
I think anybody interested in I call,
for instance, Bayesian brain hypothesis,
free energy principle should be aware.
Of because. All of the way he talks about
evolution comes from this.
Ashby's work, the Good Regulator Theorem.
It was also updated.
There was the internal model principle,
which came like a decade later.
Good Regulator
Theorem came is both these laws,
I think came in the fifties
and the forties or fifties.
And then I think in the seventies
the internal model principle was created.
But it basically says that
any system that regulates or controls
another system.
Must have. A model of that system.
Otherwise it can't regulate it.
So it seems pretty obvious.
But this talk of models
kind of starts here
that that is very familiar
to anyone interested
in like the free energy principle.
So this
this can be applied to inanimate systems.
I mean, controllers are like. House.
Like thermostats and stuff.
But Ashby was really interested
in adaptive systems,
so he was thinking about evolution.
So applied to evolution,
an organism must model its environment
if it's going to extract free energy.
And an organism is a model of its niche.
Like a key.
Is a model of the lock it opens.
So when we talk about these models
can be kind of it's kind of abstract.
But I think this model A.
T is a model to lock
it opens really explains.
How an.
Organism fits into a niche.
You can also say
like a hand fits into a glove.
But it really the.
Organism is a model of its environment.
So natural selection is essentially
an information channel
that through evolution, is pumping
in information from the external world,
from the environment into the organism
such that the organism. Is.
Encoded in the structure of reality,
in encoding the structure of the.
World and. Its design.
Include
encodes.
Information about the outside. World.
So it's kind of a.
New way to think about evolution.
Is this process of
basically
the universe is modeling itself
and waking up through this process.
Pretty interesting.
Kind of psychedelic.
Cell.
The law of requisite.
Variety is just telling you
about the sophistication of that.
Model.
So how complex does the model have to be
for the organism
to stay far from equilibrium?
Ross Ashby's lawyer says.
So. John, I'm a researcher at Cambridge.
Kind of summed it up this way in
colloquial terms,
Ashby's law has come to be understood
as a simple proposition.
If the system.
Is to be able to deal successfully
with the diversity of challenges
that its environment produces,
then it needs to have a repertoire of
responses, which is at least as nuanced
as the problems
thrown up by the environment.
So a viable system is one that can handle
the variability of its environment.
For, as Ashley put it.
Only variety can absorb variety.
So it's
what we said before with evolutionary
epistemology.
An organism evolves to become as complex
as its environmental niche requires.
It has.
To. Specifically have enough behavioral.
Responses.
Which. Map on to internal states.
So it has to have enough cognitive
states.
To respond.
To the number of challenges
that the environment
presents, challenges
in its ability
to extract energy And when.
When.
You get organisms and you get other
you get other agents, other organisms,
then.
Of course.
What the organism has to
model is much more complicated
because it doesn't have to just model
the energy source in its environment
to get food. It also has to. Model other.
Modelers, other cognitive agents.
So, yeah, basically
any adaptive system as
they are.
Behavioral repertoire
and a repertoire of accessible.
Mental.
States or for things
without brains, computational states
and the number of states
that the organism can access
should match the number of challenges,
the number.
Of states.
That could surprise the organism
by the environment.
So a cat must have
at least as many states as the ways
the mouse can evaded, and the mouse
has to have enough behavioral states
to get away So they model each other.
A sports fan, like a fencer, must have
many blocks as his opponent has attacks.
And as we said,
because behavioral responses
map on to unique internal states,
the loss of an organism
must have as many accessible states
as required by the complexity of niche.
So we set this organism
as some simple solution
to the thermodynamic problem
of being far from equilibrium.
So well-adapted species represents
a biological solution to an existential
thermodynamically dilemma.
It's a sort of living.
Evolving scientific theory about how to
most efficiently attract the free energy,
the lifeblood of existence
out of a particular niche.
Some niches present
a changing variety of challenges
that must be adapted to,
while others present hardly any at all.
So almost done here.
I know it's a lot.
Hopefully this can kind of wrap up the
ideas of show how they're all connected.
But this is still on this question
of how complex is the universe?
How complex can it get? So
Olivia, Olivia, Judson wrote this
published.
This paper called The Energy Expansions
of Evolution.
It's really nice.
You should check it out.
So she says. The history of the.
Earth system can be divided
into five energetic epochs, each
featuring the evolution of lifeforms
that can exploit a new source of energy.
These forces are geochemical energy,
sunlight, oxygen, flesh and fire.
The first two were present at the start,
but oxygen flush and fire,
all consequences of evolutionary events.
And then she. Makes this statement.
By the way. Read is.
Quotes if people haven't.
Figured that out.
So these are her words.
I forgot to put.
Quote marks so no.
Category of energy
source has disappeared.
This has over
time, resulted in an expanding
realm of the sources of energy available
to living organisms.
And a. Commitment.
Increase in diversity
and complexity of ecosystems.
So here's the way to think about it.
So taking the thermodynamic perspective
and looking at organisms
as energy flow channels,
we can think of each nation on Earth
as a sort of energy slot
for a given species
and an evolving population of organisms
efficiently searching the solution space
will eventually just by chance.
Discover a.
Solution to a thermodynamic problem
that it didn't know existed.
The discovery of a novel energy source
or energy extraction technique is both
how a new niche and a new species
come into existence.
So phylogenetic learning,
which we saw in that
chart, will naturally lead to speciation
because organisms.
Will stumble upon new.
Ways to exploit thermodynamic niches
that were previously inaccessible to.
Life. Purely for design reasons.
We're going to give
examples on the next slide.
So as.
The biosphere accumulates knowledge
through phylogenetic learning,
not only is the solution space
corresponding
to one kind of thermodynamic problem
being.
Explored here's a growing problem.
Space, each with its own unique solution.
Space
So in an evolution.
So there's an evolutionary trajectory.
That's not determined in the strict sense
envisioned by.
Laplace where like there's no freedom in
the future is like set in stone.
But there is a sort of.
Statistical determinism,
what I've been calling a non equilibrium
statistical determinism,
that guarantees that basically the.
Inevitability of this.
Emergence of a distribution of far
from equilibrium attractors.
Of varying varying.
Degrees of complexity.
So each species can be seen
as an attractor
that's exploiting this niche
and you get this
basically this diversity where you have.
Organisms
exploiting.
Like the energy niches that were kind
of. The.
Easy ones to exploit on Earth,
like the geochemical free energy
we mentioned with the origin of life
and sunlight was.
A little bit of.
A more difficult challenge.
To extract. Sunlight.
It took some time for evolution
to be able to do that.
So extracting energy
from the hydrothermal.
Vents.
Source of energy is really simple
because the energy is already
like flowing through the system,
doesn't have to do much work
to extract sunlight.
You have, you know, a moving sun.
It's a little bit more complicated.
But not nearly as complicated.
To it as organisms that eat other
organisms so better at trophic organisms
because they will have to model
not just like a sun
moving predictably feed the air, but
have to model all of these other agents,
many of which are trying
to eat them to kill you. So
basically, so
answering this question why
increasingly intelligent species emerge?
We started off with.
Reductive order tropes.
Those organisms
around hydrothermal vents.
They were a solution to the problem
of how to extract the energy
from geochemical gradients,
photosynthetic bacteria, the ancestors
of plants for the solution to extract
of how to extract all the solar energy
that was flowing to the planetary system.
So that was a big discovery
made by life is that nation
energy directly from sunlight, hetero
organisms, organisms
that eat other organisms
were the solution
to the problem of how to extract energy
from life itself.
Once life starts having to model life,
other agents with causal power
and adaptive behavior,
the computational task of extracting
free energy gets increasingly difficult
as increasingly complex species arise.
So by virtue of having to model.
Each other, the complexity
of some species gets ratcheted up by
what's known
as an evolutionary arms race.
So the line is evolving.
You know, lions. Are producing offspring.
Some of those lines will be better
at predicting the gazelles movements.
The gazelle will.
Also be creating offspring,
and some of those.
Will be better.
At predicting the lions attack.
The ones that are better predicting
are the ones that get to stick around.
So you see how you have this ratcheting
mechanism that ratchets that ratchet.
Is up. Complexity.
There's actually a principle.
Called
the Red.
Queen principle.
That. Says that.
For an.
Organism to simply stay in the game
of existence, certain organisms,
a certain species, they will have
to become increasing highly complex.
And that comes from
Alice in Wonderland.
Basically,
There's a scene
with the Red Queen in Alsace.
They're all running as fast as they can.
And Alice is like, you know,
I'm running fast as I keep running.
But I'm going nowhere.
So they're all running, but they're not
making any decisions or staying in place.
And the queen says something like,
Oh, you see here.
For that
to go somewhere, you'll have to run.
Much faster than. That.
So the idea is that for a species.
That.
Has to deal with this complex environment
just to stay where it is,
just to stay in the game of existence,
it has to become increasingly complex.
It has to keep adapting.
So one thing.
That I wanted to get into more,
but I'm not going to.
Is this idea of empowerment.
It's comes from the computational
neuroscience literature.
It's similar.
It comes from Daniel Colony,
but it's very similar to.
Harvard's Alex.
Wisner. Business grows.
He has an idea causal and tropic forcing.
But basically these
people are arguing that.
Well.
Isn't it gross is arguing that a causal.
Entropic force.
Means that like basically
it's like evolution.
You'll get a system systems
that are trying to maximize.
The number of.
States
they can respond to so that maximize.
And the number of.
States they can respond to
is mirrored by their internal diversity.
So systems naturally
try to increase the number of states.
And it's. This ability that.
Allows for intelligence,
because if you have more states going
back to this law of requisite variety,
you can respond to more challenges.
So not every.
Species is increasing empowerment.
But you.
Will get the emergence of increasing
increasingly complex.
Species because each.
Species.
Serves as food for a potential.
New species.
You will.
Get increasingly. Complex.
Species that emerge over time,
and they will be increasingly empowered,
meaning that they can respond
to more environmental states
and that they have more accessible
mental or cognitive states.
I explained some of this in the last.
Slide,
but I'll just explain a little more.
So open ended nature emergence.
Why has the evolutionary record shown
a trend of the emergence
of increasingly complex forms?
Because when all conceivable niches on
earth were filled, that wasn't the end.
New species created new niches
because the free energy slot
they provide is themselves their food.
So cybernetics
guys kind of like the last living
cybernetics, this kind of.
I'm sure there are.
Other people that call themselves that,
but he's kind of kept
that title even when it wasn't trendy.
He says it is well documented
by evolutionary biologists
that ecosystems tend to become.
More complex the number.
Of different species increases
and the number of dependencies
in other languages
linkages between species increases.
He cites E.O.
Wilson, who recently passed. Away.
Who did a lot of
work that that kind of inspired
a lot of the concepts in the book,
not just this niche emergence,
but also talking about superorganism.
So collectives and colonies,
self-organizing systems that all scales.
But he said not only do ecosystems
contain typically lots of niches
that will eventually
be filled by new species,
but there is a self-reinforcing tendency
to create new niches.
What does that. Mean?
It means the. Biosphere.
Certainly ecosystems are themselves
auto catalytic sets.
So Seth
Lloyd, he's talking about these chemical
auto catalytic sets.
But it's I should have had this.
On the earlier slide.
But it'll be a good way
to kind of show the equivalence.
Between ecosystems
satellite is auto catalytic.
Sets of reactions are powerful systems.
In addition to computing,
they can produce a wide variety
of chemical outputs.
In effect, an auto catalytic
set of reactions is like a tiny
computer controlled factory
for producing chemicals.
Some of these chemicals are constituents
of life.
Stuart Kaufman, big
you know, one of the main names
is kind of this whole talk.
He's kind of put these ideas out there
since like
the early nineties,
actually going back farther than that.
But he started
writing books in the nineties
and really gaining exposure for the Santa
Fe Institute.
He's written a recent paper,
a semi recent.
About.
Nature emergence
as an auto catalytic process.
So ecosystems are auto catalytic.
Auto categorically closed.
Self-Sustaining, reaction networks.
So there are auto agents.
That reliably drive up.
Biological diversity and complexity
as they self amplify and.
Evolve.
So when you think about it, really
all integrated
networks of adaptive systems
function as AutoCAD sets.
There's been a lot of papers showing
this is in a sense, are all kind
of assets, including the social organisms
we call societies
or civilizations.
So these networks are common
because they emerge spontaneously
when many organisms repeatedly interact
with one another and discover
synergistic collective configurations
as nature often pressures them to do.
So at the end, almost.
We've explained why complexity increases
evolution will not increase
the complexity of every species.
They will become adapted to their niche.
They will match the complexity
of the niche However, because new
niches are always emerging,
because species act.
As food for a.
Potential new species.
Because of. That process, you.
Will get this. Increase.
You will get species that emerged.
That have a higher number of a larger
repertoire of mental.
And behavioral states.
So the law of requisite variety
really explains why
more complex environments
create more complex niches.
And this is open ended There's really. No
limit to how far this.
Process can go, especially since.
Humans who are the.
Pinnacle of this process, we're not
a lot of people have been against
these kinds of uses because it seems like
it's saying that humans are.
Superior or superior.
Maybe computationally,
but not superior in any other sense
for actually part of the biosphere,
which is this integrated,
interconnected system.
So it's.
Really, you know,
it doesn't make sense to think of
as this like superior to nature, because.
The whole.
Biosphere is an organism
that we're just sort of an organ for.
We're basically the nervous system.
Of the planet.
The cybernetic global system
that people have called Gaia.
Some people don't like that name.
I think it's perfectly good name.
But that's
why complexity gets ratcheted up.
But the final
I guess part of.
This complexity increase story
is that not only do
you get increasingly complex species,
those species will interact
naturally to form.
Higher level.
Adaptive systems,
which are collectives. So.
I call this the principle
of recursive self-organization
based on Ashby's principle
self-organization.
What I'm arguing
is that when you have a biosphere
with these agents
and you have some are simple
and some are complex,
naturally those agents will interact.
When they interact.
They will in many cases discover
synergistic collective configurations.
So configurations
that make it easier for each agent
to extract the energy
they need to stay far from equilibrium.
So why do.
Interacting agents link up to. Form
stable?
The exact same reason that molecules
with the right chemical diversity
will form stable auto catalytic reaction
sets when pushed by a flow of energy
working collectively
allows the whole system to extract
more free energy with less work.
We can.
That's the whole point of synergy
is that working together
makes your workload easier
because there's distribution of labor.
And it's it's really.
Nice that this
distribution.
Of species
with some simple and some complex,
that's really
what you need to create this, like,
cybernetic adaptive system
at the level of the planet.
Because a system needs.
Diversity among its components.
In. Structure.
And function for there
to be this distribution of labor, labor
which makes it this
collective whole.
This is synergistic,
holistic, unit.
So it's actually.
Good that evolution and adaptation
isn't increasing this
the complexity of each species,
like each species
isn't becoming intelligent,
like roaches aren't becoming.
Like more and.
More intelligent over time
with no. Limit.
The biosphere wouldn't be stable
if that were the case.
It's really ecosystems
need this diversity among components.
Just as a car with made of all.
Engines isn't going to be.
Functional or an.
Organism made of all brains.
You need a variety. Of parts,
some simple.
Some complex
because they all do different functions.
So nature promotes
cooperation, collaboration, and synergy
because it is thermodynamically
beneficial for all parties.
Synergistic collective configurations
will eventually be discovered
by many components systems
that are exploding.
Greatest states are configurations.
The blind variation
and selective retention mechanism.
Mentioned organisms.
Only compete until they finally figure.
Out what that.
Working together
makes everyone's task easier.
And that goes for humans, too.
So it's kind of a moral lesson
for everybody.
The nations have to work together.
We shouldn't
get rid of the nations.
There shouldn't just be this.
Evolution. Into this.
Like global government.
Because the nations are.
Actually provide.
This diverse city
that we're saying is important.
Because.
You need this diversity of component
parts to create a division of labor.
So there's strength in diversity.
This is different
than the evolutionary picture
of survival of the fittest, whereas
there's like this idea that the strong,
the most intelligent survive.
This is saying that that's not true.
It's the most adaptive that survive
has nothing to do with strength
or intelligence.
Spots have been around
for many millions of years
despite being lost, being slow.
Because they exploit a.
Source of free energy that's not being.
Exploited by another species.
So going back
to this kind of global message,
you want nations
to retain their identities,
but you also want them at the same time
to come together
and to work synergistically.
So you basically want.
Something like a global system but this.
There has to be the optimal balance between centralization and decentralization.
Neither approach will.
Be good on its own.
There needs to be this balance.
So as long as the biosphere
is creating a growing variety
of complex adaptive systems,
some of those winter activities,
higher level, complex adaptive systems,
which will come together to form
even larger ones, this process continues.
At higher scales.
So I didn't go into this
kind of a picture that shows a brain
and then the planet,
and it's like information networks. But.
I do I hope that you talk about
Gaia and Global Brain will become
will be taken
as seriously as it should be.
They really only.
Weren't taken seriously
because they were mystical notions
associated with this word, Gaia.
Which wasn't. Even.
James Lovelock's fault.
He actually the name Gaia came
from his neighbor, who is actually.
The author of Lord of the Flies.
William Golding.
So blame him for the
for the flowery metaphor with Gaia.
But yeah,
the the biosphere is a cybernetic
organism, and we are forming something
like the global brain
and a self-replicating biosphere
is essentially the next step.
And when we are trying to care form
planets like Mars
that can be seen as the biosphere
replicating.
For humans to at.
This point in our stage of development.
We would have to.
Kind of convert Mars to like something
like a biosphere to have like oxygen.
And so you can see how it's replication
with variation,
you get the same sort of thing.
But because it's a different planet,
there's going to be variation.
It's not going to be exactly the same,
but that's how the evolutionary process
continues.
I should show this earlier.
This is just showing how like eukaryotic.
Single celled.
Organisms like amoebas will come together
to form communities like a slime.
Mold. These
multicellular organisms.
Come together to form colonies.
You see this and colony ants
actually really do form a super organism.
You can see here.
They actually build a bridge.
Out of their bodies so that some ants can
like climb across that bridge.
So it really makes sense to call it
a super organism, or at least like a
a super adaptive system or like a meta
system,
because without it, we can't make sense
of this collective behavior that's.
Functional.
Of course, human civilization,
we again see this hierarchy now.
It makes more. Sense.
We see that
these evolutionary transitions.
Oh, yeah, these are called
evolutionary transitions.
Sometimes I use the name system
transition because.
If we were.
Talking about the brain,
I would also talk about like
the emergence of a prefrontal cortex,
which is like.
A high level controller.
That's
also like a med assistant transition
so that a system
transitions are a. Little.
Extend this where it's not talking
necessarily about evolutionary
transitions, but these other transitions
where systems.
Start.
To model themselves.
So here we.
See how.
Evolution has created these.
Different memory.
Systems, these knowledge.
Repositories so it's that process.
Of recursive self-organization.
That creates new. Memory systems.
When you get go from single
celled life to multicellular life
to life with brains,
it's these are in revolutions
in information storage machinery.
So you can see how the information
the biosphere gets accumulated
through an evolutionary process.
These are the final points.
Yeah. So knowledge is power.
It's not just the hollow buzz
phrase of the digital age.
It's showing the most fundamental. Way.
Uncertainty.
Reducing information
is life's first and last weapon in.
Ongoing war with disorder.
Without knowledge, life cannot exist
for more than a moment, much less
colonize the galaxy and beyond.
It suggests that setting out on the path
toward
cosmic superiority is not a choice
that intelligent agents like Homosapiens
make upon careful reflection.
Nor is it
just some quirky ambition we stumbled.
Onto by chance.
This is the
main point humanity's collective desire
to transcend mortality.
And. Expand outward into space.
So apparently our current scientific
and technological endeavors, Space X,
this doesn't emerge as an accident.
This is an inevitable consequence
of the fact that continual knowledge
acquisition is a fundamental
biological imperative.
If life wants to persist and stay far
from equilibrium, at some point
it has to get off the planet
because the sun is going to die.
And it's these sorts of problems,
these existential.
Problems which.
Create progress
because it's our awareness of this.
Problem which forces us. To.
Search.
That configuration space
for the solutions that solve the problem.
So as natural selection plants
information from the inanimate world
into life, nature begins modeling itself
and coding its own structure
and the universe begins to wake up.
Where the cosmos come alive.
Not metaphorically, but literally.
This is Ray Kurzweil.
Image. From his book.
This clarity is near
you can see that he sees this.
He calls this the the destiny.
Of of.
Life in the universe.
And he's not shy about using that word.
Again, it's not determined
in the strict sense of replace
this kind of a statistical determinism
that creates these
series of attractors and
you've seen famous people.
So some people see that idea and
they'll have been reading Brian Greene
and listening to all these reductionist
think that's not a scientific view.
Well.
That's not true.
And I hope to see more of these people
speaking out about it.
So Christof Koch, can Confessions
of a Romantic Reductionist says
the rise of sentient life within Time's
Wide Circuit was inevitable.
Kierkegaard,
Descartes in really came up with this.
Don't have time to talk about him.
French philosopher and Jesuit
you should look into
is correct in his view
that the islands within the universe,
if not the whole cosmos, are evolving.
Toward ever greater.
Complexity and self-knowledge.
To be clear, he's not saying that Earth
had to bear life, that, you know,
primates
had to walk the African grasslands
but he says, I do believe that the laws
of physics overwhelmingly favored
the emergence of consciousness.
The universe is a. Work in progress.
Such a belief evokes
Jeremiah I don't know
from any.
Biologists and fosters,
but the evidence from cosmology,
biology and history is compelling.
So there's some
advanced blurbs for this book.
If you want to preorder it.
It comes out in June.
But every order.
That I get from now until then will count
towards my first week sales totals
that will help me get on sellers list.
If you want to preorder now
and you email. Me.
I will send you a copy.
Soon.
Of this novel
I also wrote called Rachel Mega.
I was pretty busy in the last five years.
Hey, I was I.
Went into a cave for like four
or five years, but.
This is.
A vehicle for the science and philosophy
in the book, kind of like an anti
Ayn Rand at this shrug maybe
the opposite philosophy
and the road to Omega
sets that kind of turns this phosphor
into a kind of an effort to.
Save the world with science.
Epistemology and blockchain technology.
Blockchains are part of
this self-organization process,
and that's long talk.
I never given.
That's the longest.
I ever talked at one time,
probably my wife will probably say,
Yeah, it's not true.
But I'm tired, so let's.
Open it up to questions.
And thank you for your immense patience.
It's awesome to hear and think about it.
So there are two questions in the chat.
First, is from Dean.
Dean asks, How would we explain caring
through a lens of free will or no free
will?
Would free will.
Deniers say there is no caring
when it appears that agents can or do
fully care?
Yeah, so great question.
Unfortunately,
I don't have much to say without
saying the things
that I was going to bring up in the next.
Talk, really. Explaining
what free will is.
I guess I should just say right now
kind of a brief explanation of what
I mean by free will.
So I hope I've made the
argument that agency emerges.
In. Adaptive systems that start off.
This biological organisms and to.
The person.
Self driving.
Car thing,
I just mention that real quick.
I don't think they're agents,
but I do think
it's possible to create systems
with agency
for reasons that I haven't gone into
it seems important
that these systems
have a certain type of architecture.
So not like standard computers have.
I know.
I mean, architecture
and it's not distributed
or integrated in the way the brain is.
So it's not integrating much information
so these systems
won't have causal power,
they won't be agents.
So neuromorphic.
Hardware has been.
A. Lot of people think
that's going to allow machines
that can think
and perhaps even be conscious.
I think maybe that's the way to go.
It's probably a lot more complicated
than that.
It's a step in the right direction.
So agency is real.
It's due to information gain
causal power in a system.
And it starts
it starts steering the system.
So you'll see like a bacterium performing
Teemo Texas.
But it doesn't.
Make sense to say
that the bacterium has free
will when it's going this way
and that just because it's
not predictable in the way in in an IT
system is.
So I would say that they.
Have agency,
but they don't have free will.
What free will is
and this is not my idea.
Other people have kind of been talking
in this way.
Kevin Mitchell.
Has a book. Neuro Geneticists.
He's coming out with a book
called Agents, which is all about agency
and free will. But the idea is that
we are agents with causal power.
But we're sort of
where our.
Responses like are basically.
Programed responses that are a.
Response is that. Occur.
Automatically
that are informed by this information
that's been built up through evolution
and adaptive learning.
So a lot of the time
we go through the day
and we're not really thinking
about things like driving
or like waking up
and like going to the fridge.
We're not putting conscious
thought into that,
so that wouldn't seem to be free.
Well.
To me you're kind of acting on autopilot.
So what free will is, is.
A higher level of control.
That emerges with something like a.
Prefrontal cortex
and a global. Workspace?
Basically, free will. Allow
a prefrontal cortex
allows an agent to override.
Its instinctive and automatic behaviors.
And so free will is something that
that we have, but only if.
We're exercising
this higher level of control.
It's associated with cognitive control
or executive control.
Effortful control.
And basically.
If you have.
A healthy functioning prefrontal cortex,
you're going to basically
the conscious mind is monitoring
consciousness as a monitor.
So it's it's monitoring your behaviors.
And if it.
Detects that there's suboptimal behavior
for whatever reason, like it's
just automatic kind of instinctual.
Let's say someone says something
that makes us angry and we respond.
Immediately with like pushing them.
Or something that's not a wise move.
And that may be may happen
when we're fearful
because of the amygdala response
and we just have
this automatic behavior.
But free will would.
Be when the conscious mind overrides
that process.
And the bit.
Actually the free will studies
that everybody cites
as saying that we don't have free will.
He actually never said that he said free
will is in this veto power.
Like maybe some of our voluntary.
Movements
occur. Without conscious. Thought.
But it's
our ability to override those movements.
That is the source. Of free will.
But there is more problems with that.
Actually. The studies have.
Collected a study showing that basically.
That free will.
Readiness potential,
which is like a spike
in electrical activity that occurs
before you do this voluntary movement.
This movement, we think is voluntary.
And everyone thought that this meant
that you're not really making
a conscious decision
that you could see this spike in brain
activity earlier than the person thought.
They made a voluntary,
voluntary decision.
But a new.
Study has shown that that's only the case
when we're making arbitrary decisions.
And when they had.
People making a decision about when
when to donate a large amount of money
to a charity, you actually saw this
readiness potential disappear.
And so it seems like deliberate thinking,
which is still the secretary
or frontal cortex.
And there's this distinction
between access consciousness
and phenomenal consciousness
that I didn't go into that
I would in the next talk
that Adam Safra on an integrated world
model in theory really gets at.
But the idea
is that the prefrontal cortex does allow.
Us to override. Automatic behaviors and.
That is a sort of freedom that we have.
And we also lose it
in cases of schizophrenia.
You see impaired.
Prefrontal.
Cortex activity and drug addicts.
You see impaired.
Activity in drive drug. Addicts.
You see they do repetitive behavior
even when they know that it's.
Not. Beneficial to them,
they will still engage in that.
So they're kind of stuck in this loop
for this unhealthy.
Attractor
with. Schizophrenia.
There's patients that. Report being.
Pushed around by forces
that are beyond their control.
I think that's
because when the prefrontal cortex is
basically activated.
People.
Lose this sense, this ability
to override their automatic behaviors.
And I think that's what those people are
experiencing is sort of
loss of this higher level agency
that we've called free.
Will.
Another interesting
just a final interesting thing
to mention about that.
Is Cotard's.
Syndrome.
Cotard's delusion is this delusion
where people think they're dead,
they think they're like ghost
or just not alive.
It's really weird.
A lot of people die from starvation
because they think they don't have to eat
because they think they're already dead.
You actually see from narrow
imaging studies, they've.
Showed
impaired.
Activity in the prefrontal cortex.
So maybe these people
who think they're dead.
Have lost this high level. Agency
and they feel like they're ghosts or.
Something.
As far as caring
so. Caring
is a part of like emerged
through evolution because. You.
Do have this benefit
to cooperating with each other.
Is self-organization process
that we talked about.
That happens naturally
because basically you find
that when you work together,
you minimize conflicts and
align it, you align interests.
And so caring, altruism, empathy,
all of those things are as natural
and as Darwinian as anything else.
But you have. To.
Add on to evolutionary theory.
All of this stuff about self-organization
and cooperative evolution.
As. Far as you see.
He said something about why people.
Who don't believe in free will, I.
Forget the exact point about.
The caring was that.
When when it appears that agents can
or do fully care.
Which I was.
What was the first part of it?
How would you explain caring through
a lens of free will or no free will?
Would free will deniers
say there is no caring when it appears
that agents can or do fully care?
Yeah, no, it's it flies in the face of
our everyday experience.
So like, yeah, I guess the.
The amount of contradictions
and like logic that doesn't make sense
when you go down that path of there
being no free will or agency,
you just,
you just get into absurd territory.
It's, I think when we look back, it's
kind of quaint that for so long
that we thought that everything
was determined in the strict sense.
And it's really a big issue
because these people who believe
that if they believe it,
if they take it to heart,
they're experiencing cognitive dissonance
at every moment,
you know, and the people
who argue against the agency,
they talk about religious people
having to compartmentalize, to deal with.
The real world.
But anybody who believes
that we don't have
agency has a compartment
you eyes in the same way.
Funny little conversation between
Sam Harris and his.
Wife Anika Harris,
who wrote a book called Conscious.
That is a great, accessible book.
But it leaves out.
Like everything that I've discussed
and that I would discuss about like
the Bayesian brain
hypothesis, global workspace
theory that's really going to integrate
information theory in any depth.
So like all of the.
Things that they're missing
that do explain, a lot of this.
Stuff.
Can be found in like modern neuroscience.
So we are making a lot of progress.
Towards.
Understanding the hard problem
of consciousness.
So subjective experience,
but also for your own agency.
It's funny.
Because they're having
this conversation in the podcast.
And they're discussing
whether since a belief in No Free Will.
As mentioned,
that New York Times. Article.
I think 2011 showed that
they have less moral behavior
and it can cause depression.
They're discussing
whether they should tell their daughter
about free will or not,
that she doesn't have any free will
the discussion is like,
should we tell our daughter
that she doesn't have free will?
But the actual. Discussion.
Implies that they.
Believe that they have some choice
whether to tell her or not
they're having a discussion
about whether they should do this or not.
So there's a contradiction
in their conversation
that contradicts what they believe.
What's interesting is that if they do
tell her that she has no free will.
And she believes it, she's
actually going to have negative mental.
Effects like it. Will.
You know, be. Harmful.
Assuming that she really believes it.
I don't know if it has that
in everyone, but.
You do. See studies that show that.
So if we do have free will, it's
a very bad.
Thing to be. Telling people.
And the last thing I'll say about that.
Is well, it's it's interesting
because if she's familiar with.
Epistemology
and they tell her that she doesn't have.
Free will, but she goes, OK.
That's based on a model
that has uncertainty
and that model may be disproved.
Then she might not.
Have the negative effects of free will.
So I think everyone should practice
being a good Bayesian and understand
that our models, our theories,
even the one that I just talked about,
will have errors and will be shown
to be wrong and if reductionist
do that, they won't call free
will belief in free will.
Like.
Comparing them to horoscopes, which is
just, I think, a horrible statement and.
Kind of funny.
That physicists don't like it
when like neuroscientists.
Start and biologists
start talking about physics.
It's kind of.
Strange that physicists are so sure
that we don't have free will
when they're not familiar at all
with the neuroscience behind agency and.
Freewill.
So would
you like
me to just read a comment in the chat?
Otherwise,
I think we can kind of come to a close.
If there's anything.
Yeah, I can do one more question.
Yeah, well, Marco and Dave and others,
thanks a lot for the great comments
and commentary in the chat.
I hope that Bobby,
I hope you check the live chat replay.
And Shawn O'Connor wrote,
Thanks for the good and informative talk.
Dr. Azarian mentioned
the idea of evolutionary arms race.
I was hoping to recommend
that he consider, if he hasn't, how
an interest specific evolutionary arms
race may relate.
I'm not familiar
with the interest specific. So
perhaps if you a game theory Red Queen
not between two species, but within one
species.
Yes. So you would have.
An evolutionary arms race there too?
Yeah, certainly.
If you're competing with other organisms.
And John.
Maynard Smith, who I mentioned earlier,
talking about like
this causal power of information
in biology.
He was the.
Person to bring by Norman's game theory
to biological evolution.
So he did.
He basically showed that there is
this game theory
sort of process being play it out.
I think he has examples,
use different species,
but I think within species,
you would see the.
Same sort of thing.
Of course, if it's.
Not humans, you know, if you. Have other.
Species, people are competing.
Organisms.
Are competing, you will get increased
complexity, but there are limits.
So just because theory sees
evolutionary arm races
within and between species,
there will still be a.
Limit because.
They have to model the environment.
And just modeling all these unnecessary.
Variables. Is wasteful.
So it will ratchet up.
Complexity in species. But
I think at least with. The.
Planet Earth and our biosphere, that
that humans are this sort of leading.
Envelope of. Complexity.
And so it really just is open
ended with the most complex.
Species.
So the most complex species
is the one that will.
Evolve toward. Higher complexity.
And really there might be a limit.
There are reasons to think
there are limits
to how far human biological intelligence
can emerge.
There's I mean, can evolve towards
there's something called
a centralization limit,
which is like how big our brain can get
because of reasons
like having to do with.
Like the skull and
so but
what's interesting is part of this.
Process, this evolutionary process
is as Popper and newer people
like Dennett have mentioned, continues
with science and culture and technology.
So humans really have open
ended complexity because.
Where where.
Augmenting ourselves with technology.
So while.
Biology, biological complexity may have.
Limits, there's no limits once.
We start merging with our technology
and we shouldn't
see technology as separate from.
Life.
It's an extension of biology
so the extended
phenotype, Richard Dawkins
explains, like beaver dams
considers like the Damned at the Beaver
instinctually builds.
As part of the. Whole phenotype.
So the ecosystem, the organism,
there's really no clear division
between the organism and the ecosystem.
And David Chalmers
has the extended mind hypothesis,
which says that our phones
are extensions of our minds. And
all of our.
Devices are. And
for that reason
we need to be worried about privacy.
But we also need
to not be scared of technology.
We just need to use technology
to become more human.
So we're not transcending.
Like humanity and biology technology
will allow us to become hyper biological.
Very interesting note
perhaps to close it on
any time you want the dot to,
we can make it happen.
It can be any format.
We can invite anyone else on
really awesome
and interesting to think about.
Do you want any last words?
If if I come back to talk about.
Free will and agency, it'd be great
to have Kevin Mitchell or maybe Eric
while who's done a lot of work on
top down causation and causal emergence
that was really influenced.
By influential. In the book.
If you know
people, you can Twitter tag them
or email us and email them and cc us
or just contact us
and we'll do that on our site.
Thanks. Been super fun. Thanks, Daniel.
Appreciate it.
Appreciate
you reading a draft of the manuscript
just like in a few days to give me some.
Feedback that actually helps bear little.
Mistakes. In the book.
I heard.
You mentioned Marco,
thanks to Marco and anybody else who's.
Been.
Watching and chiming in with questions.
Really appreciate it.
Sorry for the information overload.
Maybe watch this again.
Maybe my does. Or.
Maybe some legal stuff.
Delta eight.
Or or Wiley Micro.
Does want to say hi to people.
Who are actually keep up,
stay hydrated legal keep stay hydrated
legal keep stay hydrated
legal keep stay hydrated legal keep stay
hydrated legal keep stay hydrated
legal keep stay hydrated legal keep.
Stay hydrated.
Legal keep stay hydrated.
That's legal.
Keep stay hydrated.
Legal keep stay hydrated.
Gets legal keep stay hydrated.
Legal keep. Stay hydrated. Legal keep.